Oh, man, I always forget how chilly it gets when I do a cold open. But man, I probably should have worn a hat. Even gloves would have been nice, but anyway, before I freeze my beans up, welcome to Smartless. You guys, I mean, don't make me cry. It's been a month and a half. I'm so happy to see you in your house in LA. It makes me feel really good. And I know that we're going to see you later. Later today.
噢，天哪，我总是忘了在直接开场时会变得这么冷。但是，天哪，我可能应该戴顶帽子的。哪怕戴手套也好，总之，在我脑子冻僵之前，欢迎来到Smartless。各位，我是说，别弄哭我。这已经有一个半月了。很高兴在你们洛杉矶的家里看到你们。这让我感觉真的很好。我知道我们待会儿会见面。今天晚些时候。
Later today. I'm going to put my mouth on both of you right away. Hang on, hang on. One lip for each. That's another Sunday. Please stop, please stop, please stop now. Wait a minute, Jason, I know you told us a little bit about your character,
今天晚些时候。我马上就要把嘴贴到你们俩脸上。等等，等等。一人赏一个唇印。那是另一个星期天。请住手，请住手，现在请住手。等一下，杰森，我知道你跟我们稍微提过你的角色，
but is your character supposed to be clean at all? Hang on, tell us about your character. This is the start of a typical interview. Tell us about your character. What is it? As a storyteller, sorry Sean, you're gonna go, but. This is the start of a typical interview. Tell us about your character. What is it? No, because like- As a storyteller, sorry Sean, you're gonna go, but. No, well anyway, I don't really care.
但你的角色身上哪怕有一点点干净的意思吗？等一下，给我们讲讲你的角色。这是一次典型采访的开始。给我们讲讲你的角色。这是什么？作为讲故事的人，对不起肖恩，你得上了，但是。这是一次典型采访的开始。给我们讲讲你的角色。这是什么？不，因为就像——作为讲故事的人，对不起肖恩，你得上了，但是。不，好吧，总之，我其实不在乎。
I mean I care, but I mean like, is he supposed to bathe? No, and that's why I look like, you know, I mean, there's long hair and long beard and it's not, yeah, this is- Are you anxious to cut it all off or are you like, yeah? And we haven't even gone into the teeth of summer yet. I'll be going through summer in New York City with this long hair and look.
我是说我在乎，但我的意思是，他用得着洗澡吗？不，这就是为什么我看起来，你知道的，我是说，有长发和长胡子，这不是，是的，这是——你急着把它们全剃掉，还是觉得无所谓？而且我们甚至还没进入夏天最热的时候呢。我顶着这长发和这副尊容在纽约市过夏天。
How's that beard gonna feel on 16 hour days in the summer in New York? It's gonna, however bad it feels, it's gonna smell even worse. Have you been trimming it now? Cause you've got it at a length that you like? Well, we had to trim it once just for continuity so it doesn't get too, but you know.
在纽约夏天的16个小时工作日里，这胡子戴着感觉会怎样？不管感觉多糟，闻起来绝对更糟糕。你现在有在修剪它吗？因为你把它留到了你喜欢的长度？嗯，我们为了连戏不得不修剪过一次，免得长得太夸张，但你知道的。
I get, you know, people maybe be like, should we worry, is there a hotline we can call into? Well, Amanda has been to us a bunch of times and even last, I mean, to anybody who'll listen. And then I last week at dinner, she was chewing somebody's ear off about, and then he just looks like somebody new and different. I heard her, I forget who she was sitting to see.
我懂，你知道的，人们可能会想：我们该担心吗？有没有什么热线可以打？嗯，阿曼达跟我们念叨过好多次了，甚至上次——我是说，对任何愿意听的人都念叨。然后我上周吃晚饭时，她一直在对某人喋喋不休，然后他看起来就像个全新且不同的人。我听到她说的，我忘了她当时坐在谁旁边了。
She's so. She's sitting next to Scotty. No, I know. Well, it's just about different, right? I mean, I look like somebody other than the person who's been sharing a bed with her for 25 years. So she's just seeing flashing green lights all over the place.
她太——她坐在斯科蒂旁边。不，我懂。好吧，这只是关于不同，对吧？我是说，我看起来不像是那个和她同床共枕了25年的人。所以她到处看到闪烁的绿灯。
I actually think it's handsome. It is handsome. Thank you. I mean, maybe with a little trim of the beard, but the hair is. Yeah, you know who doesn't dig it? Maple, my 12 year old. She's just, she'll barely look at me.
我其实觉得挺帅的。确实挺帅的。谢谢。我是说，也许胡子稍微修剪一下，不过头发——是的，你知道谁不待见这造型吗？枫叶，我12岁的女儿。她简直，她几乎都不看我一眼。
Well, all she wants is Marty Bird back. Sure. Nice and short hair, you know, some kind of a banker look. What about the sleeves? Does Marty roll his sleeves up ever? Because Michael Bluth rolled his sleeves up. Well, he was always trying to get down to business. You know, well, I think about that every time, literally, that I turn up my sleeves. I hear you go, well, let's get down to business,
好吧，她只想让马蒂·伯德回来。当然。利落的短发，你知道的，某种银行家的造型。那袖子呢？马蒂会把袖子卷起来吗？因为迈克尔·布鲁斯会卷起袖子。好吧，他总是想直奔主题。你知道的，每次——真的，每次我把袖子卷起来时，我都能听到你说：“好吧，让我们直奔主题，”
sure, and you know, you're not wrong. But yeah, so. But you're feeling good though, you're happy to be home. I'm very happy to be home. I cannot wait to see you guys tonight. This is the first time we've done one of these for six weeks.
当然，你知道的，你没说错。不过，是的，所以——不过你感觉挺好，很高兴能回家。我非常高兴能回家。我迫不及待地想今晚见到你们。这是我们六周以来第一次做这个。
I know, people don't realize we sometimes bank episodes and we had to do that because you were directing, so we were two months ahead. Right. And how are you feeling at the end of your directing? Did it go, did everything kind of pretty much go where you wanted it to? It went even better than I'd hoped. And that was because everybody came together so, so well, crew and the cast. Yes, Amanda said it was going really great.
我知道，大家没意识到我们有时会存着几集不播，我们不得不这么做，因为你在当导演，所以我们提前了两个月。没错。你对导演工作收尾时的感觉如何？一切基本上都按你希望的方向发展了吗？甚至比我希望的还要好。那是因为每个人都配合得太好了，剧组和演员都是。是的，阿曼达说进展得非常顺利。
Yeah, I can't wait for people to see it. Really, really proud of it. And it's called Black Rabbit. It's called Black Rabbit. But for some odd, you know, Netflix, God bless them, they're not dissimilar from other companies in that like right around when Star Wars started to get rekindled and Marvel started to go,
是的，我等不及让大家看到了。真的，真的为它感到骄傲。它叫《黑兔》。它叫《黑兔》。但由于某种奇怪的原因，你知道的，网飞（Netflix）上帝保佑他们，他们跟其他公司没什么两样，那就是就在《星球大战》开始复苏、漫威开始崛起的时候，
and people really tried to like steal scripts online and like get a jump on things and like release spoilers and stuff, all studios went to a pseudonym for projects. Right. Regardless of their budget scale, like this ain't Star Wars, you know? I mean, it's a great thing, but it's not.
人们真的试图在网上窃取剧本、抢先曝光、发布剧透之类的，所有制片厂都给项目改用了化名。没错。不管它们的预算规模如何，这又不是《星球大战》，你知道的？我的意思是，这是一个伟大的项目，但并非如此。
Sean, I'm out. I was directed at you. Yeah. So we had to come up with a pseudonym per Netflix, and I was so like, oh my God, this is not a Marvel thing. We don't need a pseudonym. And I was so like over it when I got the email, and my dog Gary was just laying on my lap.
肖恩，我挂了。这话是冲你说的。是的。所以根据网飞的要求，我们必须想一个化名，我当时想，哦天哪，这不是漫威的东西。我们不需要化名。当我收到邮件时，我已经厌烦透了，我的狗加里正趴在我的大腿上。
And so I said, let's call it Gary the dog. So all over the, so the show is called Gary the dog, if you're in New York. Like all the location signs and the call sheets, so that no one figures out where Black Rabbit's shooting. So they can't get pictures. No, it's- Like it's a state secret.
所以我说，那就叫“狗加里”吧。所以到处都是——如果你在纽约，这部剧就叫“狗加里”。就像所有的外景路标和通告单上都这么写，这样就不会有人发现《黑兔》在哪里拍摄。这样他们就拍不到照片了。不，它是——就像这是国家机密一样。
Ted, I'm sorry, he's gonna call me and yell at me perhaps, but it's just, yeah, I can't wait for my actual dog to show up on set and everyone will see. You know what that reminds me of? Sorry, just made me think. When we, years ago, what is this? More than 15 years ago, we were in the, we had finished shooting, it was about to be released,
特德，对不起，他可能会打电话对我大喊大叫，但事实就是这样，是的，我等不及我真正的狗出现在片场了，到时候大家都会看到。你知道这让我想起了什么吗？抱歉，只是让我想到了。当年，我们——这是什么时候？15年前的事了，我们在，我们已经拍完了，正准备上映，
Blades of Glory, the ice skating movie. Yeah. Me and Farrell and Amy and everybody. I love that movie. Fun movie. Directed by the great Will Speck and Josh Gordon. Our friends Will and Josh directed it. So I remember I was in a cab going downtown in New York on Broadway just above Canal Street
《冰刀双人组》，那部滑冰电影。 yeah。我和法瑞尔、埃米还有所有人。我喜欢那部电影。有趣的电影。由伟大的威尔·斯佩克和乔什·戈登导演。我们的朋友威尔和乔什导演的。我记得当时我在纽约百老汇靠近运河街的一辆出租车上往南开，
and I was talking to Will on my cell phone. I guess it was probably pre, just pre smartphone, talking to Will and as I was talking to him, this woman comes up to the window of the cab and she's holding up bootleg copy. The movie hasn't been released yet. Bootleg copies of Blades of Glory. And I said, hey, Will, do you want me to grab you a copy of the movie?
我正在手机上和威尔通话。我猜那可能是前智能手机时代，正在和威尔通话，正当我和他说话时，一个女人走到出租车窗户前，手里拿着盗版光盘。电影还没上映呢。《冰刀双人组》的盗版。我说：“嘿，威尔，你想让我帮你买张电影光盘吗？”
We hadn't even had the premiere yet. And a $6 Louis Vuitton bag. You were right there on canal, right? Remember piracy was like so super bad, like the physical piracy. Yeah, good. I do that, you know, I went to, Ali Wentworth and George Stephanopoulos' house for dinner,
我们甚至还没举行首映礼呢。还有一个6美元的路易威登包。你当时就在运河街附近，对吧？还记得当时的盗版猖獗到什么程度吗，那种实体盗版。是的，好。我跟你说，我去阿利·温特沃斯和乔治·斯特凡诺普洛斯的家吃晚饭，
and I didn't have anything last minute to bring as, you know, as you do when you go into somebody's house for dinner. Sure. Classic. So I stopped on the street and I bought, Jason, one of those $6 Prada bags, and for Ali, as like, instead of like a bottle of wine or something.
我临时找不到什么东西带去——你知道的，就像你去别人家吃饭时那样。当然。经典操作。所以我顺路在街上停下来，买了一个——杰森，那种6美元的普拉达包，送给阿利，权当是带瓶酒什么的礼物。
It's so brilliant. That's gonna be my thing now. I'm just gonna buy like 20 of them, have them in my closet, and if I don't have anything, I'm just gonna bring people like pink Prada bags. That just costs $6. By the way, now you got customs on your ass. They're like.
太机智了。我以后也要这么干。我打算买个20个，放在衣橱里，如果没带什么礼物，我就直接送别人粉红色的普拉达包。只要6美元。顺便说一句，现在海关要盯上你了。他们会觉得——
Yeah. That's a great idea. Guys, let's get to our guest. She's been so kindly waiting. She's a true Los Angeles native, but counterintuitively, showbiz wasn't her, always her career path. She graduated from Vassar with a degree in psychobiology.
没错。这主意真不错。伙计们，让我们来见见我们的嘉宾。她已经等了很久了。她是个地道的洛杉矶本地人，但与直觉相反的是，演艺界并不一直是她的职业规划。她毕业于瓦萨学院，获得生物心理学学位。
Beautiful campus. And then went to work for her dad, a headache specialist. Huh? But one thing led to another, as it so often does in Tinseltown, and she ended up at the Groundlings, bit by the comedy bug. She's fluent in French, married to a Frenchman,
美丽的校园。然后去她父亲那里工作，他是一位头痛专家。啊？但事情就是这样一步步发展的，就像在好莱坞经常发生的那样，她最后加入了地面剧团（The Groundlings），迷上了喜剧。她精通法语，嫁给了一个法国人，
and I'm guessing loves french fries. All three of us would consider this person a friend, but to the rest of the world, she's one of six friends. It's Lisa Kudrow. Yeah, Lisa! Oh, with a gorgeous filter on. As soon as you said married to a Frenchman, I knew it was Lisa.
我猜她很喜欢法式薯条。我们三个都会把这个人当成朋友，但对全世界其他人来说，她是六人组之一。她就是莉莎·库卓。耶，莉莎！噢，还加了个华丽的滤镜。你一说嫁给法国人，我就知道是莉莎。
Michelle Stone. Michelle. Michelle. Michelle Stone. But I'm not fluent in French. Oh, you aren't? All right, I made that up. Michelle Stone. Michelle. Michelle. Michelle Stone. Oui. But I'm not fluent in French. Oh, you aren't? All right, I made that up.
米歇尔·斯通。米歇尔。米歇尔。米歇尔·斯通。但我不精通法语。噢，你不会？好吧，我那是瞎编的。米歇尔·斯通。米歇尔。米歇尔。米歇尔·斯通。Oui。但我不精通法语。噢，你不会？好吧，我那是瞎编的。
What about French-Canadian? Yes. Yeah. You must speak a little bit of it because your husband... Yeah, I do. I speak a little of it because my husband. So is that on purpose? You didn't want to learn it.
那法裔加拿大人呢？对。耶。你一定懂一点，因为你丈夫——对，我懂。我懂一点，因为我丈夫。所以这是故意的吗？你不想去学它。
Look, he just repeated everything. I know. That's so good. Your mirror work is phenomenal, by the way. Did you not learn the whole language so that you could tune him out when he's really going at you with some stuff? No, he just, he speaks so fast.
看，他刚才把每句话都重复了一遍。我知道。太搞笑了。顺便说一句，你的模仿秀太精彩了。你是不是故意不学整门语言，这样当他气势汹汹地冲你发火时，你就可以自动屏蔽他了？不，他只是——他语速太快了。
I couldn't. And I did take it in high school. I took four years of French. And you know Will speaks it fluently. Well, you know, I've spoken French with Michelle many times, but he ends up, you're right, he won't slow it down for you, so if you don't keep up, then he'll just flip to English,
我跟不上。我在高中确实选修过。我学了四年法语。你知道威尔法语说得很流利。嗯，你知道的，我和米歇尔说过很多次法语，但到头来，你说得对，他不会为了你放慢语速，所以如果你跟不上，他就会直接切换成英语，
because he's like, I'm not going to waste my time. Right, I know. Lisa, why do you look so pretty today, not that you don't always do, but like- Do you have a callback today? Yes, I thought this was it. So, this was an addition, and so. Because you know we're not like filming this.
因为他会觉得，我可不想浪费时间。没错，我懂。莉莎，你今天为什么看起来这么漂亮——倒不是说你平时不漂亮，而是说——你今天有试镜回访吗？对，我以为是这个。所以，这是一场增补，所以。因为你知道我们没在拍这个。
No, but you look great, your lighting is good. Your lighting is good, and I love that you have enough self respect to like blur out your background, because you don't like, Sean wants us all to look at his Canon printer. Yeah, and his little baby Yoda that's hard to get. But you're like, I'm gonna be front and center. You look great, your lighting looks great,
没有，但你看起来状态很好，光线不错。你的光线很好，而且我喜欢你很有自尊心，把背景给模糊掉了，因为你不想——肖恩非要让我们看他的佳能打印机。是的，还有他那个很难搞到的尤达宝宝。但你就想：我要成为绝对焦点。你看起来状态很好，光线看起来很棒，
you look phenomenal. No, but, because it's mayhem here. Is it? It looks like it could be a nice looking bookshelf back there. Maybe even better than Sean's. Yeah, it is. I'm actually trying to unblur it so you can see. Oh, there it is.
你看上去太棒了。不，但是，因为这里乱成一团。是吗？后面看起来像个挺好看的书架。说不定比肖恩的好。对，确实是。我其实正打算取消模糊，让你们看清楚。哦，看到了。
Oh, there it is. There it is. It's a little blurry. But you know what, that looks really nice like that. It's a shallow depth of field. At least you can kind of see this. Okay. Okay, so, go ahead.
哦，看到了。看到了。有点模糊。不过你知道吗，那样看起来真的很不错。景深很浅。至少你能隐约看到这个。好吧。好吧，那么，请继续。
I was gonna just get right to, can you help my daughter get into Vassar? You know, because we toured that campus. And she's got it. Is she interested in Jason? I don't know if she is, but I like, it looks like Hogwarts. I mean, it's so beautiful there.
我本来想直接问，你能帮我女儿进瓦萨学院吗？你知道的，因为我们参观过那个校园。而且她很有天赋。她对杰森感兴趣吗？我不知道她感不感兴趣，但我觉得，那看起来就像霍格沃茨。我是说，那里太美了。
It's really beautiful. A lot of people end up at Vassar just from the tour. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Really? And then they're disappointed they didn't go to Yale. But yeah, it's really beautiful. It's so, yeah, it's so beautiful. Was college a good experience for you?
真的很美。很多人光是参观了一趟瓦萨学院，最后就去那里上学了。对吧？对。真的吗？然后他们又为没去耶鲁而感到失望。不过是的，真的很美。真的，太美了。大学对你来说是一段美好的经历吗？
Did you? I loved it. Yeah? With all my heart. I did too. Now, were you an academic or were you just sort of doing your sports so that you could party? No, she said yeah. I wanted to say yeah to the party. You kept talking, you didn't listen, she answered.
你有吗？我爱死它了。是吗？真心实意地爱。我也是。那么，你是个学霸，还是纯粹为了玩体育顺便去混个派对？不，她说“是”。我想对派对说“是”。你一直在说话，根本没听，她已经回答了。
I like to drive people into the answer I want. Right. Well. You've forgotten, it's been a while. I was a biology major, so there was no choice but to be academic, because that's a big commitment. So what was the impetus for that? So you come out of high school,
我喜欢引导别人说出我想要的答案。好吧。你忘了，那已经是好久以前的事了。我是生物专业，所以别无选择，只能当个学霸，因为那是个很大的投入。那么，当初是什么促使你选这个的？高中毕业后，
you're kicking ass in science and math, and you're like, yeah, I'm gonna. Yeah, I thought I'll be pre-med. My dad's a doctor, my brother is starting medical school, and I thought, yeah, yeah, I'll be a doctor too. And was that interesting to you? Well, biology was really interesting to me. I loved it, biology, it's such a huge, it's such a norm.
你在科学和数学上大显身手，然后你就想：对，我要——对，我想我会读医科预科。我爸爸是个医生，我哥哥刚开始读医学院，我想，对，对，我也要当医生。那这事对你很有吸引力吗？嗯，生物学对我很吸引力。我爱死它了，生物学，它是如此宏大，如此规范。
What kind of doctor do you think you would have been? I don't know, I wasn't set on that, but halfway through I went, oh no, there's no way I'm gonna be a practicing physician. There's no way. So, but. Because, because. Because I realized I wasn't as interested in that as I was in, I liked evolutionary biology.
你觉得自己会成为什么样的医生？我不知道，我当时还没定下来，但读到一半时，我心想：哦不，我绝不可能成为一个临床医生。绝不可能。所以，但是。因为，因为。因为我发现我对那个的兴趣不如——我喜欢演化生物学。
So I was just gonna continue and do. The will's big on creation biology. Go ahead Will. Yeah, sure. But ahead Will. Yeah. I went, remember the Paula Abdul song, Vibology? No we don't. No, nobody does. I used to pretend I was going to Vibology class.
所以我打算继续深造。威尔对神创生物学很感兴趣。请继续，威尔。好吧，当然。但请继续，威尔。好吧。我想起了宝拉·阿巴杜的那首歌，《Vibology》（生命生物学）？不，我们不知道。不，没人知道。我以前常假装我要去上Vibology课。
I mean no offense to her, but nobody does. But wait, so Lisa, so your dad was a, Sean, did you say that, did he say it right? Your dad was specialized in headaches? Yeah. So what's that, talk to us a little bit about that. And yeah, I work in both offices. I got two headaches on the line with me every day.
我是说，对她没有冒犯的意思，但确实没人知道。等等，莉莎，你爸爸是——肖恩，你刚才说那个，他没说错吧？你爸爸是专门看头痛的？对。那是什么情况，跟我们稍微讲讲。对啊，我在两边诊所都工作过。我每天手里都有两颗“定时炸弹”（头痛患者）在跟我连线。
How do you get rid of them? Maybe you can help me get rid of them. It's called recasting. Okay. Well, he got a lot of headaches and he was like a family practice or internist and then decided he would switch to just treating, researching, headache.
你怎么摆脱它们的？也许你能帮我摆脱它们。这叫换演员。好吧。嗯，他经常头痛，他以前是个全科医生或内科医生，后来决定转行专门治疗、研究头痛。
Wow. So was it migraines or just the simple, the common headache? Well, at the time, from what I remember, because I worked for him. Right. From college till friends, basically. Like in the summers or full time?
哇。那是偏头痛，还是单纯的、普通的头痛？嗯，当时据我所记得的，因为我在他手下工作过。没错。从大学一直到《老友记》时期，基本上。像是在暑假还是全职？
No, full time, after college. Wow, really? That was my day job, which was really lucky. Where was that? In Encino. Okay. And at the time, there's nine different headache types at that time. Let's have them.
不，全职，大学毕业后。哇，真的吗？那是我的正职，真的非常幸运。在哪里？在恩西诺。好吧。当时，那会儿有九种不同的头痛类型。说来听听。
So I don't know. Oh, I don't know. Well, we got migraine. Are there different subsets of migraines? Of migraine, yeah. Hemalegic, ophthalmic, classical. And do you know how to treat, like you and I know your son, and the second you feel something going on, you must know all about them to know what to do with them.
所以我不知道。哦，我不知道。好吧，我们有偏头痛。偏头痛还有不同的细分类型吗？偏头痛，对。偏瘫性偏头痛、眼肌麻痹性偏头痛、典型偏头痛。你知道怎么治疗吗？——你和我，你认识你儿子，一旦你感觉有什么不对劲，你一定对它们了如指掌，知道该怎么处理。
Right, where people are, all right, great. I mean, a little, but there's a lot of new medications. My brother's a headache specialist. He's a neurologist who took over when my dad Retired be honest is he in bed with the folks over at Bayer? in bad way, but I Am a while we're pulled over here for a second. I am I mean is the headache I? Mean it's mostly just like a blood flow problem, correct?
没错，大家都在——好吧，太棒了。我是说，懂一点，但现在有很多新药。我哥哥就是个头痛专家。他是一名神经科医生，在我父亲退休后接替了班。说实话，他和拜耳（Bayer）公司的人有什么利益勾结吗？才没有，但我——在我们在路边靠边停车休息的这一会儿，我——我是说头痛这事？我的意思是，这主要只是血液循环的问题，对吧？
Or no? Well, I don't, yeah, I'm not entirely sure. But, I mean, the key. You were answering the phone, is that what you were doing there? You just doled out Tylenol? I mean, this sounds like a pretty shitty operation. I kind of knew a lot about cluster headache.
还是不对？嗯，我——对，我不是完全确定。不过，我的意思是，关键所在。你当时是在接电话吗？你在那儿就干这个？你只是负责分发泰诺吗？听起来这像是个挺操蛋的诊所。我其实对丛集性头痛（cluster headache）略知一二。
That was the subset of headaches you're around not a migraine What is that when you're around too many people? No, and is the classical headache from no, but that's a good guess. Yeah You know, I'm just about making people feel good Yeah And by the way, which leads me to, you told me before, we were hanging out at another friend's house.
那是你身边常见的那种头痛的子类型，不是偏头痛。那是什么时候发生的，当你身边人太多的时候？不对，那经典的头痛是由于——不对，但你猜得挺好。对，我就是为了让大家感觉良好。顺便说一句，这就让我想到了——你之前告诉我，我们当时在另一个朋友家聚会。
Huh? And you told me, I was asking about your family growing up and you were like, I was the least funny in the house. Yeah. And I was like, what, as a kid? Yeah. And you said, and I always found that hard to believe, so were you interested in comedy at all?
啊？你告诉我，我问起你成长过程中的家庭情况，然后你说：“我是家里最不搞笑的一个。”对。然后我说：“什么，从小就这样？”对。然后你说——我一直觉得这很难相信，所以你以前对喜剧一点兴趣都没有吗？
Like, what tickled you? Oh, well, I'm the youngest in the family, so that's always like the least competent person in the house. Get away with a lot. How many siblings? I have two. Okay. And they're older and really funny.
比如，什么东西能逗笑你？哦，嗯，我是家里老幺，所以在家里总是扮演那个最不中用的人。能逃过很多责难。你有几个兄弟姐妹？我有两个。好吧。他们都比我大，而且都特别搞笑。
And my dad is really funny and he's 91 and he still is. And so, yeah, I just would repeat what they said, bring it back to school and sometimes get in trouble because it's like six and eight years older than what was appropriate for kindergarten or first grade. But junior high, I did play production where we wrote sketches and performed them and that was huge for me. That was a very big deal. Was Saturday Night Live consequently like one of your favorite shows?
我爸爸也特别搞笑，他91岁了现在依然如此。所以，是的，我只会重复他们说过的话，把它带到学校去，有时还会惹上麻烦，因为那些话比幼儿园或一年级适当的年龄要早个六、八年。但在初中时，我参加过戏剧制作，我们自己写小品并表演，这对我很重要。那是一件大事。因此，《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live）是不是成了你最喜欢的节目之一？
Yeah, I did. I loved it. I did love it. Yeah, same. I used to watch. Yeah. Gilded Rad. Was that a gold?
对，确实是。我太喜欢了。我真的很喜欢。对，我也是。我以前常看。Gilded Rad。那是黄金时代吗？
No way. You too? Sean, no way. What a weird coincidence. Sorry, let me just get one. Oh, you liked Saturday Night Live? Fuck it, breaking news. I know. Jesus Christ. Here's what's special about me. I loved Saturday Night Live.
不会吧。你也是？肖恩，不会吧。多奇怪的巧合啊。抱歉，让我插一句。哦，你喜欢《周六夜现场》？妈的，突发新闻。我知道。天哪。我这人最特别的地方在于：我喜欢《周六夜现场》。
I loved the Beatles. Look, I loved it too. They were really good. What about oxygen? Look at what you're doing. I know. I love breathing. Yeah, I breathe oxygen.
我喜欢披头士。听着，我也很喜欢。他们真的很棒。那氧气呢？瞧瞧你在干什么。我知道。我喜欢呼吸。对，我呼吸氧气。
So was it Groundlings? Did you want to go there as maybe a path to potentially become a cast member? No, Groundlings, that was after college, and that really wasn't about, I wasn't, my goal was not Saturday Night Live, but my goal was to avoid a dramatic acting class at all costs.
所以是地面剧团（Groundlings）？你当时去那里，是把它当成未来可能成为演员阵容一员的途径吗？不，地面剧团，那是大学毕业之后的事了，那真的不是为了——我当时的目标不是《周六夜现场》，我的目标是不惜一切代价避免去上正剧表演课。
Right, right, right. Because from what I understood, they seemed like cults and it was just people taking everything way too seriously. Yeah, I was in one once and it was like that, yeah. It was like, people used it as an excuse to not move on in life. Or therapy. Ooh. Or therapy, yeah. Ooh.
没错，没错，没错。因为据我所理解的，那些课看起来就像邪教，里面的人把什么都看得太严肃了。对，我以前上过一次，确实就是那样，对。就像，人们把它当成逃避现实生活的借口。或者当成心理治疗。噢。或者心理治疗，对。噢。
Whereas the world beaters in the comedy class. Yeah, well that was the huge revelation. Yeah. Was, ooh, the comedy folk are way off. Like there's something really wrong. Well also, it's a lot of fun. Yeah. Oh, like you get to laugh and have fun all the time.
然而喜剧班里的那些人全都是世界级的赢家。对，那真是一个巨大的启示。那就是：噢，喜剧圈的人完全不一样。就像这里面有什么地方真的很不对劲。而且，这也很好玩。对。哦，就像你可以整天大笑、寻开心一样。
See, that's a little secret, that feels good. Instead of trying to make people cry. I know, but let me ask you something. Of all the stand-ups, you know who is more serious than a stand-up? The stand-ups. That's so true. About their stand-up. Wait, who would you say is funnier in person
看，这是一个小秘密，那种感觉很好。而不是整天试图把别人弄哭。我知道，但我问你个问题。在所有的单口喜剧演员里，你知道谁比单口喜剧演员还要严肃吗？单口喜剧演员自己。太真实了。对待他们的单口喜剧。等等，你觉得谁在私底下的表现比在舞台上——
than on stage, and they're great on stage? Marty Short is the funniest. Zach Galifianakis? No, Zach Galifianakis is a stand up. He's the funniest person in person, which is hard to believe, because he's so funny on stage and in stuff. Will Ferrell?
还要搞笑，而且他们在舞台上也很棒？马蒂·肖特是最搞笑的。扎克·加利费安纳基斯？不，扎克·加利费安纳基斯是个单口喜剧演员。他私底下才是最搞笑的人，这让人难以置信，因为他在舞台上和作品里就已经够搞笑了。威尔·法瑞尔？
Ferrell's got a stand up. Yeah, he never did stand up, right? Conan. Conan. Conan, incredibly funny. We'll be right back. Smartless gets support from Zip Recruiter. Summer's finally here and all those seasonal businesses
法瑞尔演过单口喜剧吗？对啊，他从来没做过单口喜剧，对吧？柯南。柯南。柯南，简直搞笑得不可思议。我们马上回来。Smartless获得ZipRecruiter的大力支持。夏天终于来了，所有那些季节性业务
are looking to hire, everything from mule packers to drama camp leaders. That means if you've got those special skills, you are in luck. There's a big demand for people like you and they're not exactly easy to find. Whether you're hiring for one of those roles or any other role, how do you find top talent before the competition gets to them?
都开始招人了，从骡队向导到戏剧夏令营营长，应有尽有。这意味着如果你身怀这些特殊技能，那你可就走运了。像你这样的人才需求量很大，而且他们可不是那么容易就能找到的。无论你是在招聘这些岗位还是其他任何岗位，如何在竞争对手挖走他们之前找到顶尖人才呢？
ZipRecruiter. And right now you can try ZipRecruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis. Found a candidate that really stands out? ZipRecruiter makes it easy to reach out to them right away. Just use the pre-written invite to apply message to personally connect with your top picks and get them interested in your opportunity. Gear up for summer with ZipRecruiter's high-speed hiring tools.
ZipRecruiter。现在你就可以在ziprecruiter.com/smartlis免费试用ZipRecruiter。找到了真正出类拔萃的候选人？ZipRecruiter让你能够轻松直接地与他们取得联系。只需使用预先写好的“邀请申请”信息，就能与你的首选人才建立私人联系，让他们对你的机会产生兴趣。利用ZipRecruiter的高速招聘工具，为夏天做好准备。
See why 4 out of 5 employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to this exclusive web address right now to ZipRecruiter for free. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, free. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. This episode is brought to you in part by Liquid IV. So I just was on that family reunion that I talked about
来看看为什么5分之4在ZipRecruiter上发布招聘信息的雇主能在第一天就招到优质候选人。现在就访问这个专属网址免费试用ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再次重申，网址是ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。本期节目部分由Liquid IV赞助播出。我刚才提到了我参加的那场家族聚会，
that was so awesome, but it was hot, hot, hot. And we were outside all the time, and I was just sweating and sweating. I put sunscreen on. I just kept sweating and outside all the time and I was just sweating and sweating I put sunscreen on I I just kept sweating and losing all that water and like and sweating and sweating not only Because of the sun just but because there was 26 people in one house But it was super fun and I just thought you know what before I left I thought enough to um pack liquid ivy with me And it's such great news because they have all those nostalgic flavors
真的棒极了，但那里真是热、热、热。我们一直在户外，我一直在流汗，一直在流汗。我涂了防晒霜。我就是一直在流汗，一直在户外，一直在流汗，一直在流汗，涂了防晒霜，我就是一直流汗，流失了那么多的水分，就像——而且一直在流汗，不仅是因为太阳，还因为一栋房子里塞了26个人。但超级好玩，我只是觉得，你知道的，在我离开之前，我觉得——我得带上Liquid IV。
Liquid IV with me. And it's such great news because they have all those nostalgic flavors now that bring you back to, you know, those free spirited summers with Liquid IV. Like the returning fan favorite, hydration multiplier cotton candy. Yeah, that's a flavor. A technicolor dreamscape of hydration. No fluff, all functional benefits with a sweet vanilla taste.
带上了Liquid IV。真是太棒了，因为他们现在有所有那些充满怀旧情调的口味，能把你带回——你知道的，那些伴随着Liquid IV的无拘无束的夏天。比如回归的粉丝最爱：棉花糖味补水能量包。没错，就是这个口味。充满科技色彩的梦幻补水体验。没有虚浮，全是功能性益处，带着香甜的香草味。
Just one stick of Liquid IV hydrates you better than water alone with triple the electrolytes of the top sports drink, plus eight essential vitamins and nutrients. So the next trip that you go on that you know you're going to be somewhere that's like hot and humid or wherever, which is basically everywhere, make sure you have a Liquid IV on you or in your car or just traveling with you in any way, because it really, really helps hydrate you and keep you hydrated.
只需一包Liquid IV，就能比单喝水提供更好的补水效果，电解质含量是顶级运动饮料的三倍，外加八种必需维生素和营养素。所以你下一次出行时，如果你知道自己会去一个又热又潮湿或者类似的地方——基本上到处都是，确保你随身携带Liquid IV，或者放在车里，或者在任何旅行途中带上它，因为它真的、真的对补充水分、保持水润大有帮助。
Turn your ordinary water into extraordinary hydration with Liquid IV. Get 20% off your first order of Liquid IV when you go to liquidiv.com and use code smartless at checkout. That's 20% off your first order when you shop better hydration today using promo code smartless at liquidiv.com.
将你普通的饮用水变成非凡的水合体验，尽在Liquid IV。访问liquidiv.com购买Liquid IV的首单产品，并在结账时使用优惠码smartless，即可享受8折优惠。访问liquidiv.com使用促销码smartless，今天就开始享受更好的补水体验，首单立享8折优惠。
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. I talked about this before, but it's very, very dangerous to compare yourself and your life to others. I know it's really easy to do that, especially with social media and looking at people's lives who are like, oh, you know, that person's life seems better than mine,
本节目由BetterHelp赞助播出。我以前说过这个，但是将自己和自己的生活与别人进行比较，是一件非常、非常危险的事情。我知道这很容易做到，尤其是有了社交媒体，看着别人的生活，心里会想：“哦，你知道的，那家伙的生活好像比我的好，
or they have more than me, or whatever it is, but it's really unhealthy, and you really gotta check yourself to get off of social media. and what might help you do that and cope with that is therapy. Because comparing yourself to others is a total joy killer. It's so easy to look at someone's social media
或者他们拥有的比我多，”不管是什么，但这种做法真的很不健康，你真的得克制自己，远离社交媒体。而能帮助你做到这一点并应对这种心态的方法就是心理治疗。因为与他人比较绝对是快乐的消灭者。看一眼别人的社交媒体太容易了，
and think they've got it all figured out. But the truth is, everyone's got their own stuff going on behind the scenes that you can't see. Therapy can help you focus on what you want instead of what others have, so you can start living your best life if You're thinking of starting therapy give better help a try It's entirely online designed to be convenient flexible and suited to your schedule
然后就会觉得他们把一切都经营得完美无缺。但事实是，每个人在你看不到的幕后都有自己的焦头烂额。心理治疗可以帮助你专注于你想要的东西，而不是别人拥有的东西，这样你就可以开始过上最好的生活。如果你正考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线上进行，旨在为你提供便利、灵活的服务，并完全契合你的日程安排。
Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with the licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge Stop comparing and start focusing with better help visit better help comm slash smart list today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash SmartList. And now back to the show. Having said all that, who, who, what I wanted to know, Lisa, who is in your class at groundless? Conan. So Conan was? I would have quit if not for Conan. That must have been exhausting. Oh, oh, sorry.
只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可匹配持证治疗师，并可随时免费更换治疗师。停止比较，开始专注于 BetterHelp，今天就访问 better help点com 斜杠 smart list，第一个月可享 10% 的优惠。网址是 BetterHelpHELP.com 斜杠 SmartList。现在回到节目中。话虽如此，谁，谁，丽莎，我想知道，谁在你在 Groundlings 的班上？柯南。所以柯南是？如果不是为了柯南，我早就退出了。那一定很累。哦，哦，抱歉。
I thought you were gonna go the other way. He wouldn't make you quit. We'll cut that one, Will. Yeah, you were weird. Tell us about that at the Grounding. Yeah, it was nuts. Well, I couldn't take Grounding classes because they wouldn't let me
我还以为你要走相反的方向呢。他不会让你退出的。威尔，我们会剪掉那一段。是的，你当时很奇怪。给我们讲讲在 Groundlings 的那段经历吧。是的，太疯狂了。嗯，我不能上 Groundlings 的课，因为他们不让我
because I hadn't had enough experience with anything. So they sent me to Cynthia Seghetti, an improv teacher at the Coronet, which is now, God damn it. Largo. Thank you, yeah. And I went to the first class and thought, oh no, these are not my people and I can't do this.
因为我对任何事情都没有足够的经验。所以他们把我送到了辛西娅·塞盖蒂那里，她是科罗内特剧院的一位即兴表演老师，现在，见鬼。拉戈剧院。谢谢，是的。我去上第一课时心想，哦不，这些人不是我的同类，我做不到这一点。
Commit, I don't know what that means. And they're all embarrassing me with their like, you know, space ball, with an emotional adjustment, like grr. I went, I can't do this. I think I'm out of acting forever. And then the next week I said, all right, just go. You committed to this, just go.
全身心投入，我不知道那是什么意思。他们都在用他们的那种方式让我难堪，你知道的，太空球，带着情绪调整，比如“吼”。我心想，我做不到了。我想我永远退出表演了。然后第二周我说，好吧，去吧。你既然承诺了，就去吧。
And I was a little late and everyone was up there. It's like, no, no, I don't wanna break the flow. I'll just sit here and watch and die. And they were lifting a disc or something. An imaginary disc. Yes. Yeah. Right, space for a mime actually.
我稍微迟到了一点，每个人都在台上。就像，不，不，我不想打破节奏。我就坐在这儿看，然后死掉。他们当时在举一个盘子什么的。一个虚拟的盘子。是的。对，实际上是模仿默剧的空间。
And so one of them was doing it, and it was Conan, this tall, really tall redhead guy, is lifting the disc and when he's angry, he's just kind of angry and he's just really lifting a disc or throwing the space ball without too much. And the teacher, Cynthia, was saying, good commitment. I went, oh, that's commitment. It's not embarrassing.
其中一个人在做这个，那是柯南，这个高个子，非常高的红头发家伙，在举着那个盘子，当他生气的时候，他只是那种生气，他真的在举着盘子或者扔太空球，没有太多别的。老师辛西娅说，很好的投入。我心想，哦，这就是投入。这并不尴尬。
You're just really doing it. And I thought, okay, that guy. So I made sure, I made a beeline to him, said hi, I'm Lisa. That was really good. He said, I'm Conan. And we became best friends. That's amazing.
你只是真的在做。我想，好吧，就是那家伙。所以我确保，我径直朝他走去，说嗨，我是丽莎。刚才演得真好。他说，我是柯南。然后我们成了好朋友。太棒了。
That's amazing. And is it true that Conan gives you credit for him taking over Letterman? Not credit, no. But a little push. Kind of, I mean, because he was asked to produce that show. Lorne Michaels asked Conan to be the producer.
太棒了。传闻柯南把接替莱特曼主持节目的功劳记在你的头上，这是真的吗？不是功劳，没有。但有一点推动。某种程度上，我是说，因为有人邀请他制作那个节目。洛尔·迈克尔斯邀请柯南担任制作人。
So they were looking for someone to be the host and Conan would say, I want someone smart but funny, but who can have a conversation with writers, authors and politicians. And I said, well, that's you. So you should do it. Because nobody replaces David Letterman, you're nobody.
所以他们在寻找主持人，柯南会说，我想要一个聪明但有趣的人，一个能与作家、名家和政治家对话的人。我说，嗯，那不就是你吗。所以你应该去做。因为没有人能取代大卫·莱特曼，你就是独一无二的。
You know, so it's kind of the only. And at this point, was he the head writer on Saturday Night Live? No, he was at The Simpsons. Oh, that's right, The Simpsons. Had he been at Saturday Night Live or not yet there? No, he had already been, that's how Lauren Michaels knew him. Okay.
你知道的，所以这可以说是唯一的选择。在那个时候，他是《周六夜现场》的首席编剧吗？不，他在《辛普森一家》。哦，对，是《辛普森一家》。他之前在《周六夜现场》待过吗，还是还没去过？不，他已经去过了，洛尔·迈克尔斯就是那样认识他的。好吧。
That's wild, and you guys have been close ever since, that's so cool, and then you actually went back to the Groundlings to teach, right? So then you became Cynthia. No, while you're at the Groundlings, you can teach. And I taught Cheryl Hines, was in my class. Some other people too, and I don't remember. I voted Will Ferrell into the Groundlings maybe.
太疯狂了，你们从那以后一直很亲密，太酷了，然后你实际上回到了 Groundlings 教书，对吧？所以后来你变成了辛西娅。不，在 Groundlings 期间，你可以教书。我教过谢丽尔·海恩斯，她在我班上。还有其他人，我不记得了。我可能投票让威尔·法瑞尔加入了 Groundlings。
Wow, that's so cool. Nice vote. Not me alone, but yeah. Well, but I would, you might wanna do a lap on that one though. Sure. I'd do a lap. An influential vote.
哇，太酷了。投得好。不是我一个人，但确实如此。嗯，不过你可能想就那件事做个回顾。当然。我想回顾一下。很有影响力的一票。
David Spade, sorry, just had another comedian who's very funny off. Yeah. Lisa, have you ever done stand-up? No, well, no. Would you? Would you? No.
大卫·斯佩德，抱歉，刚刚脑子里闪过另一个非常有趣的喜剧演员。是的。丽莎，你做过单口喜剧吗？不，嗯，不。你会吗？你会吗？不。
Why? Because I don't wanna write jokes. But what about if somebody wrote them for you? What about being a host of a late night show? But what about, let's say, the monologue that the j Jimmy's do, or, you know, like, would you do that? Would you be comfortable with that?
为什么？因为我不想写笑话。但如果有人为你写呢？当深夜秀的主持人怎么样？但是，比如说，吉米们做的那个独白，或者，你知道的，你会做那个吗？你觉得那样会自在吗？
No. No. Could you do late night? No. That's what I'm saying. What do you mean? Like, be a guest? Yeah, would you host a late night talk show?
不。不。你能做深夜节目吗？不。这就是我要说的。什么意思？比如，当嘉宾？对，你会主持深夜脱口秀吗？
What do you mean? You know what I mean. Okay, now you're being confrontational. See, I think that'd be such a great job. You listen to me. Yeah. No, I... Now Sean, you've done, and Will, you've done,
什么意思？你知道我的意思。好吧，你现在开始对抗了。你看，我觉得那会是一份很棒的工作。你听我说。是的。不，我……肖恩，你做过，威尔，你做过，
you've guest hosted Kimmel Show. Yeah. So you've done monologues up front there. What, is that a comfortable thing? I like it. Yeah, I would be really interested in trying it. No, but it's not just the monologues, because then you have to interview people,
你作为嘉宾主持过吉梅尔的节目。是的。所以你在前面做过独白。那，那是一件让人舒服的事吗？我喜欢。是的，我真的有兴趣尝试一下。不，但这不仅仅是独白，因为接下来你得采访别人，
which you all three know how to do. And that can be death. Yeah, I don't think I can do that. But it would be hard, I think it would be hard by ourself. Look how fucking shitty we are at it. But we get to like, it's cut three ways. If it was just me interviewing somebody,
你们三个都知道怎么做。而那可能会是死路一条。是的，我觉得我做不到。但那会很难，我觉得我们自己做会很难。看看我们在这方面有多他妈的逊。但我们得像，节目剪成三个部分。如果只有我一个人采访某人，
I would, you'd answer a question, and I'd just be nodding at you and going, huh, that's great, I would not have my next question ready. That's the hard part of the job. No, that's my fear too. No, but even if somebody gives you the question, no, it would be hard just to give the impression that I'm interested.
我会，你回答了一个问题，而我只会对你点头说，嗯，太棒了，我根本准备好下一个问题。那是这份工作最难的部分。不，这也是我的恐惧。不，但即使有人把问题给你，不，光是要给人留下“我对这很感兴趣”的印象就已经很难了。
Right. Yeah. But you know, I'll bet, I would love to watch the talk show, and Letterman was kind of good at this too, although he was a decent fellow about it, but he'd still let you see in just a little bit that he's not feeling this guest. This guest is not hitting the ball back like they should.
对。是的。但你知道，我敢打赌，我很喜欢看脱口秀，莱特曼在这方面也挺擅长的，尽管他在这方面是个正派的家伙，但他仍然会让你隐约看出他其实并不喜欢这个嘉宾。这个嘉宾并没有像他们应该的那样把球接回去。
They're acting like they're doing us a favor by being on the show. And I used to like that. I used to like to try to read him. And nine times out of 10, the guest kind of deserved it. They were kind of being jerks and he wasn't helping them. And he kind of let them sink. I think you'd be good at that, Willie.
他们表现得好像能上这个节目是在施舍我们一样。我以前很喜欢那样。我以前喜欢试着揣摩他。十有八九，那个嘉宾确实罪有应得。他们有点像混蛋，而他并没有帮他们。他有点任由他们陷入困境。我觉得你在这方面会很在行，威尔。
I don't know. I'm just looking at Lisa and I'm remembering, Lisa, have I ever told you this? I'm remembering the first time we ever met. Uh oh. Should Sean and I take a look back? We've remembering the first time we ever met. Uh-oh. Do you guys go to Sean? Should Sean and I take you to the park? We've gone on to work together.
我不知道。我正看着丽莎，我想起了，丽莎，我跟你说过这事吗？我想起了我们第一次见面的时候。哦，噢。肖恩和我应该回顾一下吗？我们正在回忆我们第一次见面的时候。哦，噢。你们去找肖恩吗？肖恩和我应该带你去公园吗？我们后来一起合作过。
Lisa and I did Bojack Horseman together. We've done some stuff, right? And it was really great. Great show, my God. And you were so great on it. But the first time we met, it was like the first year of Arrested Development. And somehow we were at the Beverly Hills Hotel, there was something going on,
丽莎和我一起合作过《马男波杰克》。我们做过一些项目，对吧？真的非常棒。天哪，这是一部好剧。你在里面演得太棒了。但我们第一次见面，那好像是《发展受阻》的第一年。不知怎么的，我们在贝弗利山酒店，当时有某种活动，
you were meeting someone for lunch, and you were standing, do you remember this? No. You probably don't. I know, you told me this. I think I told you this, and you were still on, Friends was still like maybe this last year. Okay.
你正在和某人见面吃午饭，你当时正站在那儿，你还记得这事吗？不。你可能不记得了。我懂，你跟我说过这事。我想我跟你说过这事，当时你还在拍，当时《老友记》可能还在拍最后一年。好吧。
And I was such a huge fan, as you know, because I've bored you with it at least so many times, such a huge fan of The Comeback. I mean, I just frickin' loved it. What a genius, underappreciated show. You were so brilliant in it. And our good friend Mike Schur was on the staff and just an amazing, amazing, amazing show. For me was a mind blower. And so I just said hi to you and you, we sort of said hi and I made some stupid joke and you, you know, and you go, Oh, you are kind of like your character
我是你的超级粉丝，如你所知，因为我已经用这个烦扰过你无数次了，我是《回来》的超级粉丝。我是说，我简直他妈的太爱它了。多么天才、被严重低估的节目啊。你在里面的表现太精彩了。我们的好朋友迈克·舒尔当时在剧组工作，这是一部绝对、绝对、绝对精彩的节目。对我来说简直是个震撼。所以我只是跟你打招呼，然后我们算是打了个招呼，我开了一个愚蠢的玩笑，而你，你知道的，你说，哦，你真的挺像你在那个节目里的角色的。
on that show. I walked to my car and I was like, fucking what? I was being funny. I was trying to be funny. It really hurt my feelings. I drove and I crashed my car. I know, you told me. And I said then, I'm saying it now. I'm sorry.
我走到我的车前心想，他妈的什么鬼？我当时在搞笑。我当时想搞笑。这真的伤了我的自尊。我开车时还撞了车。我知道，你跟我说过。我当时那么说，现在我也这么说。我很抱歉。
Did you literally get in an accident? You got in an accident? No, I didn't get in. No, I didn't get in an accident. But I was like, cause she was like a big star. You know what I mean? And I was didn't get it. No, I didn't get in an accident, but I was like, I really, cause she was like a big star, you know what I mean? And I was like, whew. Still is.
你真的是出车祸了吗？你出车祸了？不，我没有出。不，我没有出车祸。但我是觉得，因为她是个大明星。你知道我的意思吗？而我当时没反应过来。不，我没有出车祸，但我是觉得，我真的，因为她是个大明星，你知道我的意思吗？我就觉得，哇。现在依然是。
I know. At least. But I felt like a ding dong, anyway. Tell my sister Tracy, who's listening from Wisconsin, cause I know I still love this show. By the way, I'm sorry, Tracy, I just, I've been gone for a month and a half. I just got home to that really sweet
我知道。至少是这样。不过反正我觉得自己像个大傻瓜。告诉我的妹妹特蕾西，她正在威斯康星州收听，因为我知道我依然很喜欢这个节目。顺便说一句，对不起，特蕾西，我只是，我离开了一个半月。我刚回到家，就看到了那个非常贴心的
Wisconsin Badger golf shirt you said he talked about it. No, but I had not opened it yet. I was still in New York and You know Tracy, I don't like it No, I love it I love it I love it and thank you, thank you, thank you. That's very sweet. But at least for my sister who may not know this story, I always find it so interesting, and a lot of people do know, but if you wouldn't mind, first of all, I want to go, Scottie and I watch episodes of Cheers a lot. Like, we'll take like 10 years off and then we'll watch Cheers again. Yeah.
威斯康星獾队高尔夫球衫，你说过他谈到过这个。不，但我还没打开它。我当时还在纽约，你知道的，特蕾西，我不喜欢它——不，我爱死它了，我太爱它了，谢谢你，谢谢你，谢谢你。这太贴心了。但至少对于可能不知道这个故事的妹妹来说，我一直觉得这非常有意思，而且很多人都知道，但如果你不介意的话，首先，我想说，斯科蒂和我经常看《欢乐酒店》的剧集。比如，我们会隔个10年不看，然后再把《欢乐酒店》拿出来看。对啊。
You guys are nuts. Yeah, crazy. When you pop on there, it was like, oh my God, is that one of your first jobs on Shears? Or was that the first job? That was the first guest starring job on Tell Us Joke. With Woody Harrelson, it's so cool, you were so great on that.
你们这群疯子。对，太疯狂了。当你突然出现在那儿的时候，就觉得，哦天哪，那是你在《欢乐酒店》里的第一份工作吗？还是那是第一份工作？那是《欢乐酒店》里的第一份客串工作。和伍迪·哈里森一起，太酷了，你在那集里演得太棒了。
Like Taft Hartley. Oh wow. Really? Yeah. And you met Jimmy Burroughs for the first time right there. Yeah, yeah. And I think that's where I was going, so then Frazier, right, or Mad About You then,
就像塔夫特-哈特利工会。哦，哇。真的吗？对。你就在那儿第一次遇到了吉米·伯罗斯。对，对。我想我当时正要说到这儿，然后是《欢乐一家亲》，对吧？或者接下来是《我为卿狂》，
what was next? Frazier. Frazier. Well not next after I did other guest stars. Apparently I was on Coach like three times. Apparently. So what I am, as IMDB made a mistake. Do you not remember that experience?
接下来是什么？《欢乐一家亲》。《欢乐一家亲》。不过不是紧接着的，我还演过其他客串。显然我在《教练》里演过三次。显然是这样的。所以，呃，IMDb搞错了。你难道不记得那段经历了吗？
That's right. Recently I worked with Linda Lavin and she said, and that's the thing that caught what, Jimmy? What? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you?
没错。我最近和琳达·拉文合作，她说，这就是那件吸引了，什么，吉米？什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你是什么？
What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you?
吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？
What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? What was the thing that caught you? Yeah, yeah, yeah. So when you were Ursula on Mad About You. And that I do remember. Okay, so and that's the thing that caught what? Jimmy Burroughs' attention, the network's attention, or what? No, David Crane's boyfriend, partner, is Jeffrey Cleric, and Jeffrey was a writer for Mad About You at the time. So when they were casting Friends,
吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？吸引你的是什么？对，对，对。所以当你在《我为卿狂》里饰演乌苏拉的时候。那个我确实记得。好吧，那吸引的是什么？吉米·伯罗斯的注意，电视台高层的注意，还是什么？不，大卫·克兰的男友兼伴侣是杰弗里·克莱里克，当时杰弗里是《我为卿狂》的编剧。所以当他们在为《老友记》选角时，
Jeffrey said, what about Lisa, who's playing Ursula? That might be a good Phoebe. Wow. Right. But you didn't, but you filmed the part of Roz for Frasier before that? Yeah, yeah, I got, no, no, I didn't film it. I got fired before that. Oh, let's get off of Frasier.
杰弗里说：“那个正在演乌苏拉的丽莎怎么样？她或许是个不错的菲比。”哇。没错。但你不是在那之前就已经为《欢乐一家亲》试镜并拍摄了罗丝的角色吗？对，对，我，不，不，我没拍。我在那之前就被解雇了。哦，咱们别聊《欢乐一家亲》了。
You got fired from Frasier? Frasier, yeah. Isn't that interesting though? Is it because you put hands on Kelsey or David or you're just running him over? The dog had an issue with the dog. You know me so well, oh my God. You had an issue with the dog. Is it put hands on like ringing necks
你被《欢乐一家亲》解雇了？《欢乐一家亲》，对。不过这不是很奇妙吗？是因为你对凯尔西或大卫动手动脚了，还是你把他们给撞了？那只狗，跟那只狗有点问题。你太了解我了，哦天哪。你跟那只狗有问题。动手动脚是指掐脖子
or put hands on cupping somebody? No, no, no, that's striking somebody or shaking somebody vigorously. Well, you know how violent I am. Isn't it wild how just everything works out? Like you go get that, so you get that, and then it's just always. Yeah, I know. And it was devastating to get fired, but of course.
还是动手动脚是指捧着别人的脸？不，不，不，那是殴打某人或用力摇晃某人。好吧，你知道我有多暴力。一切都是最好的安排，这难道不是很奇妙吗？就像你去争取那个，然后你就得到了那个，接着就一直……对，我知道。被解雇简直是毁灭性的打击，但当然啦。
So when you went in for the part of Phoebe on Friends, you knew Jimmy already, Jimmy Burroughs, for those who don't know, directed the pilot and a bunch of the first season of Friends, the great Jimmy Burroughs, whom we all adore. So when you went to audition for that, he was already very familiar with you. He loved you, to audition for that, he was already very familiar with you. He loved you, evidently.
所以当你去试镜《老友记》里的菲比时，你其实已经认识吉米了——吉米·伯罗斯，对于那些不知道的人来说，他执导了《老友记》的试播集以及第一季的大部分剧集，伟大的吉米·伯罗斯，我们所有人都非常崇拜他。所以当你去为那个角色试镜时，他其实对你已经非常熟悉了。显然他很喜欢你。
Well, he was familiar enough that, you know, he got fired from the last thing. By the way, do you know when we shot the reunion for Friends, or was it there, or something else, like a Jim Burroughs celebration, Yeah. where I learned I was the only cast member for Friends that had to audition for Jimmy Burroughs' celebration where I learned I was the only cast member for Friends that had to audition for Jimmy Burroughs.
嗯，他熟悉到，你知道的，他把我从上一部戏里给开除了。顺便说一句，你知道吗？当我们拍摄《老友记》重聚特辑时，或者是在那儿，还是别的什么地方，比如吉米·伯罗斯的庆祝活动上，我才知道我是《老友记》里唯一一个需要为吉米·伯罗斯试镜的演员。
Really? Really? Really? Why is that? Because I had just gotten fired from Frasier. Wow, wow. And he was directing it. So Jimmy had been instrumental in your firing from Frasier.
真的吗？真的吗？真的吗？为什么会这样？因为我刚被《欢乐一家亲》解雇。哇，哇。而且他是那部剧的导演。所以吉米在促成你被《欢乐一家亲》解雇这件事上起到了关键作用。
I don't know. He probably could have fought it. Probably. It sounds like it. You know. So he felt bad. He probably could have fought it. Probably. It sounds like it. I mean, let's listen. So he felt bad. He probably didn't want to cast you in Friends, was like, ah, listen, I already fired this kid once,
我不知道。他当时可能本可以为我争取的。有可能。听起来是这样。你知道的。所以他觉得很抱歉。他可能本可以为我争取的。有可能。听起来是这样。我是说，听着。所以他觉得很抱歉。他可能不想让我在《老友记》里试镜，心想：“啊，听着，我已经把这小姑娘开除过一次了，
give her this job. No, he's not like that. You know what? He's smarter than that. No, but when I had my audition, I didn't. Let's pull him into this call. Yeah, can you just hold one second? No, when you went to your audition?
给她这份工作吧。”不，他不是那种人。你知道吗？他比那更聪明。不，但当我试镜的时候，我没有……把他也拉进这个通话里吧。对，你能稍等一秒钟吗？不，当你去试镜的时候？
When I auditioned, it's just this small room. He's sitting at a desk, I'm in a chair, and the audition was like a little monologue thing. Where was it, do you remember? At Warner Brothers. And when I'm done, he just went, no notes. Wow. And I thought, all right.
我去试镜的时候，那只是一个小房间。他坐在桌子后面，我坐在椅子上，试镜就像是一段很短的独白。在哪儿，你还记得吗？在华纳兄弟。等我演完后，他只说了一句：“不用提意见。”哇。我想，好吧。
But that's a good, that's. I don't know what that means. That's pretty good. Like it's hopeless, or it's perfect good idea. I don't know what that means. That's pretty good. Like it's hopeless or it's perfect. No, you did really well. Do you remember, do you remember, so you do that, that's probably in the spring of like 94, maybe 93, something like that, right?
但这挺好，这……我不知道这是什么意思。这相当不错。就像是没救了，还是完美的主意。我不知道这是什么意思。这相当不错。就像是没救了，还是完美的主意。不，你演得真的很好。你还记得吗，你还记得，所以你做了那个，那大概是在94年春天的样子，或者93年，差不多那样，对吧？
Here she comes, Mrs. Mary Lynn Hedder. Of Friends, where you do the pilot. 94. 94, right, so I was right the first time. So you do the, I know. I don't know, yeah. And you do the pilot, you do the, you shoot the pilot, and do you remember the, I know. And you do the pilot, you shoot the pilot. And do you remember the different,
她来了，玛丽·林·赖斯尔女士。关于《老友记》，你在那里面拍了试播集。94年。94年，对，所以我第一次就猜对了。所以你拍了，我知道。我不知道，对。然后你拍了试播集，你拍了试播集。你还记得那些不同的……
like do you have a moment like a year later or six months later where you're like, holy shit, my life has changed so quickly? No. No, you don't. No, it wasn't like that. It was Mad About You that changed a lot for me because I had been fired from Frasier
比如你有没有过这样的大致时刻：一年后或者六个月后，你突然觉得，靠，我的人生怎么变化得这么快？没有。没有，并没有。没有，不是那样的。是《我为卿狂》对我的改变很大，因为我被《欢乐一家亲》解雇了，
and then I did a guest star on Mad About You. They had me back, I'd already done a guest star the first season, so now I'm there for a different character. And my agents had said, you're not doing this. They called like in the morning, can she just come in an hour? The character is called Waitress, there's no name. And my agents at the time were saying, no, no, you can't, it doesn't even have a name,
然后我在《我为卿狂》里客串了一把。他们又让我回去了，第一季的时候我已经客串过了，所以这次我是来演一个不同的角色的。我的经纪人当时说：“你不能接这个。”他们一大早就打电话来：“她能一个小时内赶过来吗？”这个角色叫“女招待”，没有名字。我当时的经纪人说：“不，不，你不能去，这甚至连个名字都没有，
don't do this. I said, I'm not in a position to say no. And it's to me the best show and I'm doing it. And by the end of the week, Danny Jacobson said, you're so funny, would you be okay doing five more episodes? Just went, yes. Oh, thank God you did that.
别接这个。”我说：“我可没有资格说不。而且在我看来这是最棒的节目，我要接。”到了周末结束的时候，丹尼·雅各布森说：“你太有趣了，你愿意再多演五集吗？”我直接就说：“好啊。”哦，谢天谢地你这么做了。
There's my rent for the year, I don't have to get another day job, yay! Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. But then your dad's scrambling to find somebody to hand out the Tylenol. Yeah. You kinda screwed your dad over a little bit, luckily. Lisa, can you say or can you remember,
这下我一年的房租有着落了，我不用再去找别的日常工作了，耶！对，对，对，对。但随后你爸爸手忙脚乱地去找人来分发泰诺。对。你算是有点把你爸给坑了，好在……丽莎，你能说一说，或者你还记得吗，
do you know why you were fired from Frasier? I don't, it just wasn't working. I don't know. So you were like mid-week, you were like through the producer run through, through the network run through or something and then they made a switch? But during the run throughs,
你知道你当年为什么会被《欢乐一家亲》解雇吗？我不知道，就是感觉不太合适。我不知道。所以你大概是在剧中途，比如通过了制作人彩排、电视台彩排或者类似环节之后，他们就换人了？但在彩排期间，
because Jimmy was saying like this isn't working, so just don't even. Right. They have to fix it. Because I was trying to like what's not working, what can I do? But I think they did make a casting mistake with me because I went to the network with Perry Gilpin.
因为吉米一直在说这行不通，所以就别……没错。他们必须得改。因为我当时一直在想，哪里行不通，我能做点什么？但我觉得他们在选角上确实对我有误判，因为我和佩里·吉尔平一起去电视台面试的。
Yeah. Oh wow. And for whatever reason. Who got the part? Yes, and so I think they were just correcting a mistake. Got it. Got it, got it, got it. Because Perry should have always been Ross.
对。哦，哇。不管出于什么原因。是谁得到了那个角色？对，所以我觉得他们只是在纠正一个错误。明白了。明白了，明白了，明白了。因为佩里本来就应该演罗丝。
Right, right, right, right, right. Yeah, it's such a funny, you guys, well we've talked about it a little bit, but you've been fired from a role that you just weren't right for before, have you? I have, I mean, sort of. I, right, right, right, right. Yeah, it's such a funny, you guys, well we've talked about it a little bit, but you've been fired from a role that you just weren't right for before, have you? I have, I mean, certainly. I got fired and then retired. Or the stuff that you don't get
对，对，对，对，对。是的，这太有趣了，你们，好吧，我们之前也稍微聊过这个，但你以前也曾被某个你其实并不适合的角色解雇过，对吧？我有过，我是说，某种程度上。我，对，对，对，对。是的，这太有趣了，你们，好吧，我们之前也稍微聊过这个，但你以前也曾被某个你其实并不适合的角色解雇过，对吧？我有过，我是说，当然。我被解雇了，然后就退休了。或者说那些你没争取到的机会，
and then you end up being available for the thing that you, I mean, like, you know, that classic story of you and Rain on Arrested Development. Well, first of all, no, the year before I got fired off that pilot, that it was, the show became Still Standing, and when it went to, it got picked up for series
然后你最终反而有空去接那个真正适合你的角色，我的意思是，就像，你知道的，你和雷恩在《发展受阻》里的那个经典故事。嗯，首先，不对，就在我被那个试播集解雇的前一年，那个剧后来成了《为人父母》，当它被……它被预订为整季剧集时，
and I didn't get picked up. But it would never felt right. And had I not been fired, at the time I was like, fuck, what a great job. Had I not been fired, I wouldn't have been available for rest of the film. And it was the same casting director, Deb Burelski, whom I adore.
而我却没有被选中。但那种感觉一直不对劲。要是我当时没有被解雇，我当时的想法是：靠，多么棒的工作啊。要是我没被解雇的话，我就没空去演《发展受阻》了。而且两部剧的选角导演是同一个，黛布·伯鲁斯基，我很崇拜她。
But can I ask you guys something when you are fired from something? Yeah. I mean, I know for me, there's that moment of, wow, maybe this just isn't supposed to work out, this career choice. Oh yeah, all the time. Oh, you did have that when?
不过我能问你们个问题吗，当你们被某个项目解雇的时候？对。我是说，我知道对我来说，会有那种时刻：“哇，也许这行真的不适合我，这个职业选择是个错误。”哦，对，一直都有。哦，你也有过这种感觉，是在什么时候？
I have it every day, still. Oh, yeah, it's not working out. You know what, Lisa, I did, like, my thing was like, I was so, I ended up getting fired, and I said, I was kinda like, fuck them like, I was so, I ended up getting fired and I said, I was kind of like, fuck them. And I was living in New York at the time, Amy was doing SNL and I was like, I'm gonna do, I happened to do, you know what, that summer I happened to do,
我每天都有，到现在还是。哦，对，这行根本行不通。你知道吗，丽莎，我当时，我的情况是，我当时非常……我最后被解雇了，我说，我当时有点像“去他们的”。我当时住在纽约，艾米在做《周六夜现场》，然后我想，我要去……我碰巧在那个夏天，你知道吗，
or no, a couple summers before, I happened to do a reading at New York Stage and Film, one of those reading things at Vassar. Yeah, yeah, powerhouse. Yeah, yeah, so you're there for like a week and you're kind of workshopping a new play and I met this playwright and this director and he ended up calling me and saying,
或者不对，是前几个夏天，我碰巧在纽约戏剧与电影公司做了一次剧本围读，就是在瓦萨学院办的那种围读活动。对，对，动力之屋。对，对，所以你在那里待大约一个星期，参与排练一出新话剧，我遇到了这位剧作家和这位导演，他最后给我打电话说，
I'm gonna do this play with a new group off Broadway. And so I was like, I'm just gonna stay in New York and do theater and fuck TV. That was my thing was like, they're not firing me, I'm firing them. I'm firing the whole TV business like they cared. And. Right, that'll show them.
我要和外百老汇的一个新剧团合作这出戏。所以我当时就想，我要留在纽约演戏剧，去他的电视剧。我当时的想法是，不是他们解雇我，是我解雇他们。我要把整个电视行业都给解雇了——就好像他们会在乎似的。对。没错，这下可给他们好看的了。
But that kind of made me get my head around it, feel better about myself. That's how I dealt with it. That's great. But you're right, Lisa. It's so, all you need is just one firing and you think maybe I just don't, because it's so thin what we do.
但这种心态帮我调整好了状态，让我对自己的感觉好多了。我是这么处理这件事的。这太棒了。但你说得对，丽莎。太……你只需要经历一次解雇，就会觉得也许我真的不行，因为我们做的事情太脆弱了。
It's not backed up by credentials and diplomas and four years of finishing school and all of that stuff. It's just, it's so sort of subjective. And also Lisa, think about it, similarly to you, within a year my life changed after that moment where I thought it was all done, my life changed forever, same for you. Yeah, yeah, that's right.
它背后没有资历、文凭、四年的贵族学校教育或者诸如此类的东西支撑。它只是，它非常主观。而且丽莎，想想看，和你类似，在那之后的一年里，我的人生发生了改变——就在我以为一切都结束的那个时刻之后，我的人生永远改变了，你也是。对，对，没错。
I mean, but that's what's important to me, like for younger artists who definitely have talent. And yes, you can be discouraged, but then you've gotta pull yourself back up. Like, you know, that can't be your mindset for too long, otherwise it won't work out. It's just not going to work out. It'll win. That mindset will win. We'll be right back.
我是说，但对我来说这才是最重要的，比如对于那些绝对有才华的年轻艺术家来说。是的，你可能会气馁，但随后你必须振作起来。就像，你知道的，那种心态不能维持太久，否则就走不通了。这样是行不通的。那种心态会毁了你。我们马上回来。
Smartless is brought to you in part by Audible. Listening on Audible helps your imagination soar. Whether you listen to stories, motivation, expert advice, any genre you love, you can be inspired to imagine new worlds, new possibilities, new ways of thinking. Find the genres you love and discover new ones along the way. Explore bestsellers, new releases, plus thousands of included audiobooks, podcasts, and originals that members can listen to all they want with more added all the time. Audible makes it easy to be inspired and entertained
SmartLess节目部分内容由Audible赞助播出。在Audible上听书能让你的想象力尽情驰骋。无论你听的是故事、励志内容、专家建议，还是你喜爱的任何流派，你都能获得启发，去想象新的世界、新的可能性、新的思维方式。寻找你喜爱的流派，并在探索中发现新的类型。探索畅销书、新书上架，以及数千部会员可以无限畅听的包含有声书、播客和原创作品，而且还会不断添加更多内容。Audible让你轻松获得启发和娱乐，
as part of your daily routine without needing to set aside extra time. There's more to imagine when you listen. So everybody knows I really love food. Talk about food a lot. May not be the food that you like, but I really like it. So when I'm not in my kitchen making a tuna fish sandwich or a peanut butter sandwich or mac and cheese
将其融入你的日常生活，而无需特意抽出额外的时间。当你聆听时，有更多的想象空间。所以大家都知道我真的很喜欢食物。经常谈论食物。可能不是你喜欢的食物，但我真的很喜欢。所以当我不﻿在厨房里做金枪鱼三明治、花生酱三明治、奶酪通心粉，
or whatever I want, I listen to Taste by Stanley Tucci, which is true. Stanley Tucci is such a good guy and a funny guy. And I'm such a big fan of him as an actor. I love him in everything he's ever done. This book is written and told with Stanley's signature wry humor. And it's a great way to listen to him tell his stories
或者任何我想吃的东西时，我在听斯坦利·图齐的《品味》，这是真的。斯坦利·图齐真的是个很好的人，也很幽默。我非常崇拜他作为演员的才华。他演过的所有作品我都非常喜欢。这本书是用斯坦利标志性的讽刺幽默感撰写和讲述的。听他讲述自己的故事是一种绝佳的体验，
about falling in love with food and making dinner and growing up in Westchester, New York. It's just really, really interesting how he ties it all together. A very, very, very entertaining listen. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smart list or text smartless to 500 500.
关于他如何爱上食物、制作晚餐以及在纽约韦斯特切斯特长大。他把这些串联在一起的方式真的非常、非常有趣。这是一部非常、非常引人入胜的有声书。作为Audible会员，你每个月可以从整个目录中选择一本作品永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。请访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500 500。
That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. Everything to play for has taken on its biggest challenge yet. We've had two-parters, we've even had three-parters.ters. This is a four parter and the reason why we're giving it four podcasts is it's probably the greatest individual rivalry in Premier League history.
这就是 audible.com/smartless，或者发送短信 smartless 到 500 500，即可免费试用 Audible 30 天。audible.com/smartless。Everything to play for 迎来了至今为止最大的一次挑战。我们做过分上下集的节目，甚至做过分三集的节目。这是一档分四集的节目，之所以我们要用四期播客来讲述它，是因为这可能是英超联赛历史上最伟大的个人对决。
Yes, Arsene Wenger versus Alex Ferguson. We've bitten off more than we can chew. And what it reminds me of, I saw a video on social media the other day of a python having swallowed a duvet. And the vets were trying to get the duvet out of the python. I thought that is like me and Colin having to skip over FA Cup finals because there's so much to talk about when it comes to Wenger and Ferguson. Doubles, trebles, pizza round the face, it has everything. If you want to listen to the podcast equivalent of a python swallowing a duvet, follow everything to play for on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You
没错，温格对阵弗格森。我们这次接了个啃不动的硬骨头。这让我想起，前几天我在社交媒体上看到一段视频，一条蟒蛇吞了一条羽绒被。兽医们正试图把羽绒被从蟒蛇肚子里弄出来。我想这就像我和科林不得不跳过足总杯决赛一样，因为每当谈到温格和弗格森时，有太多事情可聊了。双冠王、三冠王、把披萨糊在脸上，应有尽有。如果你想收听蟒蛇吞羽绒被般精彩的播客，请在 Wondery App 或你获取播客的任何地方关注 Everything to play for。你
can binge seasons early and ad free right now on Wondry Plus. I'm Mike Bubbins. I'm Ellis James. And I'm Steph Guerrero and we're convinced that our podcast the socially distant sports bar is going to be your new Favorite comedy podcast with just a little bit of sport thrown in you don't have to love sport like sport Or even know anything about sport to listen because nobody has conversations which stay on topic and it's the same on our podcast We might start off talking about ice hockey but end up discussing, I don't know, 1980s British sitcom Alo Alo instead. Imagine using the word nuance in your pitch for Alo Alo.
现在就可以在 Wondery Plus 上提前畅听各季节目，且无广告干扰。我是迈克·布宾斯。我是埃利斯·詹姆斯。我是斯蒂夫·格雷罗，我们坚信我们的播客《保持社交距离的体育酒吧》将成为你最喜爱的喜剧播客，里面还加了一点点体育元素。你不需要热爱体育、懂体育甚至对体育有任何了解也可以收听，因为没有人会一直按着主题聊天，我们的播客也是如此。我们可能从冰球聊起，但最后讨论的却是不知怎么聊到的，比如20th世纪80年代的英国情景喜剧《金翅鸟》之类的。想象一下在推介《金翅鸟》时用上“细微差别”这个词。
He's not cheating on his wife, he's French. It's a different culture. If you like me and Mammoth, or you like Alison Fanny's Football League, then you'll love our podcast. Follow The Socially Distant Sports Bar wherever you get your podcasts. The Socially Distanced Sports Bar, it's not about asymmetrical overlords. James podcasting from his study and you have to say that's magnificent. From Wondery, I'm Indra Varma and this is The Spy Who. This season we open the file on Oleg Penkovsky, the spy who defused the missile crisis.
他可没对妻子不忠，他是法国人。这是不同的文化。如果你喜欢我和《猛犸象》，或者喜欢艾莉森·法尼的足球联赛，那你一定会爱上我们的播客。在任何你获取播客的地方关注《保持社交距离的体育酒吧》。《保持社交距离的体育酒吧》，这可不是关于不对称的霸主。詹姆斯在书房里录制播客，你必须得说这太宏伟了。来自 Wondery，我是英德拉·瓦玛，这里是《间谍》。这一季我们翻开了奥列格·彭科夫斯基的档案，这位间谍化解了导弹危机。
It's 1960 and the world's on the brink of nuclear war. However, one man in Moscow is about to emerge from the shadows with an offer for the CIA. His name is Oleg Penkovsky. As a Cold War double agent, Penkovsky wants to supply the US with the Soviet Union's greatest nuclear secrets. But is this man putting his life on the line to save the world, or is he part of an elaborate trap?
那是1960年，世界处于核战争的边缘。然而，莫斯科的一个男人即将从阴影中走出来，向中情局抛出橄榄枝。他的名字叫奥列格·彭科夫斯基。作为一名冷战时期的双面间谍，彭科夫斯基希望向美国提供苏联最核心的核机密。但这个男人是在冒着生命危险拯救世界，还是他只是一个精心设计的陷阱的一部分？
Follow the Spy Who on the Wondry app, or wherever you listen to podcasts. Or you can binge the full season of the Spy Who on the Wondry app or wherever you listen to podcasts. Or you can binge the full season of the Spy Who defused the missile crisis early and app free with Wondry Plus. And now back to the show. Lisa, let me ask you this on this on this subject, because I was just talking about it, because sometimes, I'm sure you guys have had it too, and like, you know, my parents will be like,
在 Wondery App 或你收听播客的任何地方关注《间谍》。你也可以在 Wondery App 或你收听播客的任何地方提前且无广告畅听《间谍》的全季节目。现在回到节目中。丽莎，在这个话题上我想问你一个问题，因为我刚才正聊到这事，有时候，我确信你们也有过这种经历，比如，你知道的，我父母会说，
so and so's grandnephew wants to be an actor. Well, you talked to him, and I was thinking like, I wanna be generous, but also, and I was just talking about it two hours ago, and of what would I say, what would you do if you were 20 years old today starting over again? It's such a different world from when we all started. Yeah. Certainly the show business is so much different because of social media, et cetera. What would you say to somebody
某某的曾侄孙想当演员。你会跟他聊聊，我当时就在想，我既想慷慨大方，但同时，我两小时前才刚讨论过这事，如果换作现在的你，要是你20岁重新开始，你会对他说什么、你会怎么做？与我们当年刚出道时相比，现在的世界已经完全不同了。是的。当然，由于社交媒体等因素，现在的娱乐圈大不相同了。你会对那些
who is trying to do what you're doing to your 20 years, 20 year old you today? What would you say? So different now. Well, is it that different in a, I think it's different in a good way though, because what I had always said was, say yes to everything except porn. That was always my advice. Sean, yeah.
试图走你这条路的人说些什么？对现在的20岁的你自己说，你会说些什么？现在太不一样了。好吧，这真的有那么大的不同吗？我觉得从某种好的方面来说确实不同，因为我以前总是说，除了成人电影，对所有事情都说“好”。我一直以来的建议就是这个。肖恩，对。
Darn it. Well, but it worked out anyway for you. And that's a joke everybody listening. No, still say no to porn, I think. I mean, I guess it depends on your level of comfort. Yeah, and what you think porn is. Everything's okay now. That's another issue.
可恶。好吧，不过对你来说结果还是挺好的。在座各位，这只是个笑话。不，我想对成人电影还是要说不。我是说，这大概取决于你的舒适区。是的，以及你觉得什么是成人电影。现在什么都行了。那是另一个问题了。
But that was it. It was just say yes to everything. You have no idea who's gonna see it. You have no idea what it's gonna lead to, what you're gonna learn from doing it. And now everyone has a camera and can post it on something. Yeah. The tough part, I think for me, it would be like,
但事情就是这样。就是对所有事情都说好。你根本不知道谁会看到它。你根本不知道这会带来什么，你从中学到什么。现在每个人都有个摄像头，可以把它发到任何平台上。是的。对我来说最难的部分，我想我会对某人说——这些大概是不切实际的衡量标准——那就是：
I would say to somebody, and these are unrealistic sort of parameters, is that like, yeah, go do it if you don't need it in order to make a living. And also if you don't need it in order to make a living, and also if you don't need to be hired to find validation about your talent. Like those are two really hard things to, like my confidence was always tied to being chosen,
是的，如果你不需要靠它来谋生，那就去干吧。还有，如果你不需要靠它来谋生，而且你不需要通过被雇佣来寻找对自己才华的肯定。要把这两点做到真的很难，比如我的自信总是和被选中、被录用绑定在一起。
to being employed. You know, like if I didn't get the job, I can't feel good about myself. Once I got the job, I was fucking perfect. I was just bulletproof, and then inevitably the job is over, and that good about myself. Once I got the job, I was fucking perfect. I was just bulletproof. And then inevitably the job is over. And that's tantamount to being fired. And you gotta go find another job.
你知道的，如果我没得到这份工作，我就没法自我感觉良好。一旦我得到了这份工作，我他妈就是完美的。我简直是刀枪不入，然后不可避免地工作结束了，自我感觉良好……一旦我得到了这份工作，我他妈就是完美的。我简直是刀枪不入。然后不可避免地工作结束了。而这就等同于被解雇。你得去再找一份工作。
And until I got that job, I couldn't feel good about myself. And so my self-esteem was always tied to employment. Employment is not in your control. So therefore the way you feel about yourself is not in your control. And that was a real tough thing for me. And then also, if you have to, if it's your only way to make a living,
直到我得到那份工作，我才能自我感觉良好。所以我的自尊心总是和就业绑定在一起。就业是不受你控制的。因此，你对自己的感觉也就无法由你控制。这对我和来说真的是一件很难熬的事。而且，如果你必须靠它谋生，
it's really stressful. Yeah, I agree and I think that you're right. And we've talked about this before again, which is I've never believed, I think it's really dangerous to tie your self-worth into what you're doing, right? But at the same time, JB, think about it, your perspective is different because you grew up
那压力真的很大。是的，我同意，而且我觉得你说得对。我们以前也讨论过这个，那就是我从来不相信——我觉得把你的自我价值和你在做的事情绑定在一起是非常危险的，对吧？但与此同时，JB，想想看，你的视角不同，因为你从小
working your whole life since you were a kid. Sean and I came into it later from other parts of the world. You grew up in Los Angeles, Lisa, but again, you came from a different world, kind of a whole different world. Yeah, and I was being employed at a time when I didn't really care about being employed, and then when it became important to be employed,
一辈子都在工作，从你还是个孩子的时候就开始了。肖恩和我后来从世界的其他地方进入这个行业。你在洛杉矶长大，丽莎，但话说回来，你来自一个不同的世界，某种程度上完全是另一个世界。是的，我被录用的那阵子，我根本不在乎自己有没有工作，而当拥有一份工作变得重要的时候，
things had sort of dried out for me. And so, I needed to make money and I also needed to feel good about myself. And it was just tough. And it forced me to do some of the work that people should do earlier, which is get a good base of self-esteem and self-worth before you enter the workforce. Right, that's hard to do, period.
我周边的机会差不多都枯竭了。所以，我需要赚钱，我也需要自我感觉良好。这真的很难。它逼着我去完成一些人们本应该更早完成的事情，那就是在进入职场之前，先建立起良好的自尊心和自我价值感。没错，这很难做到，真的。
I mean, that's sort of like the whole lifelong commitment. Exactly, that's the journey right there. I have something to say about friends still. Okay, okay. Just one thing. Sorry, we got a caller here, go ahead. Yes, we were all friends, yeah. Is that it?
我的意思是，这差不多就像是一生都要去践行的事情。没错，这才是真正的旅程。关于《老友记》，我还有话要说。好的，好的。就一句话。抱歉，我们这儿有个来电，请讲。是的，我们当时都是朋友，对吧。就这些吗？
Okay. What are your thoughts about the ebb and flow of the show? Because I remember when I moved to LA, Friends was obviously massive. I moved in 95 and it was huge. And then there was a hibernation period after it was over and then Netflix took over and there was this resurgence of popularity,
好吧。你对这部剧的起起伏伏有什么看法？因为我记得当我搬到洛杉矶时，《老友记》显然火得一塌糊涂。我是95年搬过去的，它当时太红了。后来在它播完之后有一段沉寂期，接着网飞（Netflix）接手了，然后它的人气就迎来了复苏，
not that it ever went away, but it just came back, this massive, almost as big as when it first started. And what was that like? Did you feel that change again? Or were you just like, I'm still here, it doesn't affect me? Yeah, but I mean, it was always on in syndication.
倒不是说它曾经消失过，但它就是卷土重来，人气暴涨，几乎和它刚开播时一样火。那是种什么样的体验？你再次感受到这种变化了吗？还是觉得：我还是我，这对我没什么影响？是的，但我的意思是，它一直在轮播重播。
So. Yeah, but that's what I'm saying. But even in syndication, it didn't seem like it made as big of an impact as it did when it moved to Netflix. Right, that's what I heard. Well, yeah, but that's the fun, speaking more to the phenomena of Netflix than anyone else. But it was so popular and it's undeniable, right?
所以。对，但这就是我想说的。即便是在轮播重播的时候，它似乎也没有像在网飞上线时那样产生那么大的影响力。没错，我听说也是这样。嗯，对，但这很有趣，更多是说明了网飞的现象级效应，而不是其他任何人。但它太受欢迎了，这是不可否认的，对吧？
So like we're just sort of stating the obvious. It was so incredibly popular and still is, but so popular and also so internationally popular. It was so big, it kind of, it was able to do a thing that very few American shows did, which was sort of transcend sort of language and all sorts of things. I mean, every one of my adult friends in the UK
所以我们就好像在陈述一个显而易见的事实。它曾经极其受欢迎，现在依然如此，而且在国际上也极其受欢迎。它体量如此庞大，以至于它能够做到极少数美国电视剧能做到的事情，那就是超越语言和各种界限。我是说，我在英国的成年朋友里，
are massive fans of friends in a way that's really- Everybody I know. It's true. But Lise, you went on to, you're one of the few who had such an iconic character on a television show and then you achieved what seems like from the outside the impossible and parlayed that into and broke out of Phoebe, which a lot of people can't do. Oh, you think I did?
每一个人都是《老友记》的超级粉丝，那种程度真的是……我认识的所有人都是。确实如此。但丽莎，你后来……你是为数不多的在电视节目中塑造了如此标志性角色的人，然后你取得了在外人看来不可能实现的成就，把那个光环延续下去，并摆脱了菲比的影子，很多人都做不到这一点。哦，你觉得我做到了？
You did, Romia Michele's high school reunion, opposite of sex. I analyzed this, you were so fucking great, analyzed this. And then... The comeback? The comeback, so that's what I was getting to because I'm a massive, massive fan of that show. I've seen every episode, I love it so much. Valerie Cherish is one of the funniest characters I've ever seen in my whole life. Thanks!
你确实做到了，《罗米和米歇尔的高中重聚》，《性爱对立面》。我分析过，你演得他妈的太棒了，我分析过这个。然后……《回来》？《回来》，这就是我要说到的，因为我是那个节目的超级、超级粉丝。我看过每一集，我太喜欢了。瓦莱丽·切里什是我这辈子见过最搞笑的角色之一。谢谢！
Truly, and then I was on it, so thank you. And then, but talk to me about that character and how you came up with it. Is it based on a real person? And if you haven't seen The Comeback, see The Comeback. It's so funny. That's incredible. Thanks, I know, I'm the most proud of The Comeback.
真的，而且我还在里面客串过，所以谢谢你。然后，但跟我聊聊那个角色以及你是怎么构思出这个人物的。她是根据真人改编的吗？如果你还没看过《回来》，一定要去看《回来》。太搞笑了。太棒了。谢谢，我知道，我最引以为傲的就是《回来》。
Yeah, you should be, it's so great. The most. But how did you come up with that character? Well, I mean, it's a composite of people, honestly. I'm not trying to, you know, be coy. But it just was a composite of a lot of different people that you'd see on talk shows. I had a character at the Groundlings called
对，你确实应该为此自豪，真的太棒了。最自豪。但你是怎么构思出这个角色的呢？嗯，我是说，老实说，她是好几个人的合体。我可不是在故弄玄虚。但她确实是我在脱口秀节目里见过的许多不同人物的合体。我在“土地班”喜剧团时有个角色叫
your favorite actress on a talk show. That's funny. That's funny. And is that a little bit of Valerie Cherish? Well, it was, I mean, because it was way before Valerie Cher is that a little bit of Valerie Cherish? Well, it was. I mean, because it was way before Valerie Cherish. Can we speak to Valerie Cherish? No, I'm just kidding.
脱口秀里你最喜欢的女演员。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。那算是一点瓦莱丽·切里什的影子吗？嗯，算是吧，因为那是在瓦莱丽·切里什之前……那算是一点瓦莱丽·切里什的影子吗？嗯，算是吧。我是说，因为那远在瓦莱丽·切里什之前。我们可以跟瓦莱丽·切里什对话吗？不，开玩笑的。
Yes, you can. Welcome to Smartless. This is nice. Thanks. Oh my God, you actually did it. I love it. You actually did that. I love it.
可以的，请便。欢迎来到 SmartLess。这感觉真好。谢谢。哦天哪，你真的这么做了。我太喜欢了。你真的这么干了。我太喜欢了。
I was being coy. All right. Valerie, Valerie, are you comfortable being on a podcast at all? If it's being broadcast, I'm comfortable. It's so funny. Wait, okay, so it's a little bit of background. She says everything like it's a sitcom. Like a tag.
我刚才是在故弄玄虚。好吧。瓦莱丽，瓦莱丽，你上播客觉得自在吗？只要是在广播，我就觉得自在。太搞笑了。等等，好吧，所以这有一点背景。她说话的语气就像在演情景喜剧。就像一个包袱。
She says it's a tag or a button. Wait, what? Yeah, a button. A blow. A blow. A, what? Yeah, button. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's so good. A blow. A blow. A blow.
她说这是个包袱或者笑点。等等，什么？对，一个笑点。一个漂亮的小收尾。一个漂亮的……什么？对，笑点。对，对，对。太棒了。一个收尾。一个收尾。一个收尾。
It's so funny. Are you gonna do more of them? Oh God, I would love to. Well, why can't it be Curb Your Enthusiasm? You just do a season whenever you want. Well, because Larry David can call up HBO and say, all right, I want to do more, okay. Yeah, but the comeback is huge.
太搞笑了。你还会拍更多吗？天哪，我太想了。那为什么不能像《抑制热情》那样？你想什么时候拍一季就拍一季。因为拉里·大卫可以给 HBO 打电话说：“好了，我想拍更多，就这样。”对，但《回来》的影响力很大。
The comeback was huge. Well, yeah, well see, I want to do more, okay. Yeah, but the comeback is huge. The comeback was huge. Well, yeah, we'll see. Michael Patrick King is busy with, and just like that. That's actually something, yeah. What is your level of effort and interest in creating new shows, new characters? Where does all that sit with you right now? Where do most of your interests lie?
《回来》的影响力很大。好吧，好吧，走着瞧吧，我想拍更多，好吧。对，但《回来》的影响力很大。《回来》的影响力很大。好吧，好吧，我们拭目以待。迈克尔·帕特里克·金正忙着拍《就此》呢。那确实是一回事，对。你现在创作新节目、新角色的精力和兴趣程度如何？你现在的主要兴趣都在哪里？
That's such a good question. I mean, I've spent the last few years being really interested in not producing and just acting and being cast. And so I've done that, it's just none of it has come out yet. But it will, all this year. Is it producing boring? Is it boring?
这问题问得太好了。我是说，过去几年我一直对“不再担任制作人、只专注于表演和听从选角”这件事非常感兴趣。所以我已经这么做了，只是这些作品都还没上映。但都会在今年上映。制作节目很无聊吗？无聊吗？
No, it's not that it's boring. I mean, for me it just felt, yeah, it's a lot of work. It's a little boring for very little payoff, yeah. Yeah, I got tired of making other people money, and big money that way. Right, so there's that, but then also, it just felt so fraught, you know, also just with like HR issues and things like that.
不，倒不是说它无聊。我是说，对我来说只是觉得，对，那有大量的工作。付出微薄的回报却要承担一点无聊，对。对，我厌倦了为别人赚钱，而且是以那种方式赚大钱。没错，有这方面的原因，但除此之外，它也让人感到极其心力交瘁，你知道的，还要处理人事问题之类的事情。
So I just wanted, okay, I'm not producing. Yeah, because as an actor, everything's done basically and then you get cast and then you're just a few weeks away from actual shooting. You like, you even skip all the pre-production and all that stuff, not to mention all the development and the pitching and the budgeting and all of that. It's just like so many different points in the process
所以我只想说，好吧，我不当制作人了。对，因为作为演员，一切基本都敲定了，然后你被选中，接着离正式开拍就只有几周时间了。你甚至可以跳过所有的前期制作以及所有那些繁琐的工作，更不用说所有的开发、推介、做预算之类的事情了。在这个流程中有太多不同的节点
that can go wrong and you can be frustrated, yeah? Yeah, no, that's exactly right. I mean, I loved, I produced a show, Who Do You Think You Are? Which is not scripted. I was on it. Yes, oh my God, that was such a good episode. I mean, it was so fascinating.
可能会出岔子，会让你感到沮丧，对吧？对，不，完全正确。我是说，我喜欢——我制作过一档节目《你是谁？》。那是个无剧本节目。我还在里面出镜了。对，哦天哪，那集太棒了。我是说，太迷人了。
Yeah, and I loved doing that. I mean, I loved the research stage. The editing and how you're gonna lay out the story for the person to discover and where the documents are found and that stuff. I loved doing that show, producing that. That's great. And that's it. But I mean,
是的，我很喜欢做那个。我是说，我喜欢查资料的阶段。剪辑以及你将如何为当事人抽丝剥茧地展开这个故事、去哪里找到档案文件之类的。我很喜欢做那个节目，担任它的制作人。那太棒了。就这样。但我是说，
everything else is like, wow. And that's it. I don't know. But the comeback, yes, I mean, because I write the comeback with Michael, so yeah. Love it, just love it. It's so good. So wait, really quick, I have something else to talk,
其他的一切就像是，哇。就这样。我不知道。但《回来》的话，是的，因为《回来》是我和迈克尔一起写的，所以是的。太喜欢了，简直爱不释手。太棒了。等等，说回正题，我还有别的事要聊，
I wanna talk about Time Bandits, because I loved that movie as a kid, and now you're in the series, Time Bandits. Oh, you did, you loved that movie. I loved it. I've seen it a ton of times. Yeah. I loved it. I liked it too, I saw it in the theater too.
我想聊聊《时间劫匪》，因为我小时候超级喜欢那部电影，现在你参演了剧版的《时间劫匪》。哦，你看过，你很喜欢那部电影。我太喜欢了。我看了好多次。对。我太喜欢了。我也很喜欢，我当时还在电影院看过呢。
What, can you tell me a little bit, Taika Waititi, right, he's directing, or wrote it, or both, or? Both, Taika and Jemaine Clement. Yup. What about Ian Morris? And Ian Morris, yes, fantastic, but when I first learned about it was just
能跟我讲讲吗，塔伊卡·维迪提，对吧，他是导演，还是编剧，还是两者都是？塔伊卡和杰梅奈·克莱门特两人兼任。没错。伊恩·莫里斯呢？还有伊恩·莫里斯，对，非常棒，但当我第一次听说这个项目时，只是
Taika and Jemaine wrote the pilot. And I went, well, I don't care, yes. Do I need to read it? Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I'd be happy with those. It's in New Zealand, I've always wanted to see? Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I'd love to read it with those kind of people. And it's in New Zealand. I've always wanted to see New Zealand. Right.
塔伊卡和杰梅奈写了试播集剧本。我就觉得，好吧，我不在乎，我接。我需要读剧本吗？对，没错。对，只要有这些人，我演什么都行。它在新西兰拍，我一直想去……对，没错。对，我很乐意和这样的人合作。而且是在新西兰。我一直想去新西兰看看。对的。
So, yes. They still have the Hobbitville there from Lord of the Rings. Yeah, not where we were shooting. That's not where you're shooting, okay. And I didn't see that. But it would work well, because time management. Because I was busy working.
所以，当然。他们那里还保留着《指环王》里的霍比屯呢。对，不是我们拍戏的地方。那不是你们拍戏的地方，好吧。所以我没看到。但那应该挺合适的，因为时间旅行……因为我忙着工作呢。
All right, fine. So I didn't see much. Someone who's got a future in locations, okay. So this is a series that you've shot that's yet to come out? It's coming out July, I think 26th. Nice. On Apple.
好吧，好吧。所以没怎么到处看。看来有人很有外景地的天赋啊。好吧。所以这是一部你已经拍完但还没播出的剧集？大概在7月26日播出吧。太棒了。在苹果（Apple）平台上。
On Apple. That's so exciting, I can't wait to see it. I know, I'm trying right now with this system to watch, you know this PICS thing and they send you and then you can try to watch things on it? It's really hard. It's very difficult. Tell me about, if you can try to watch things on it. It's really hard. It's very difficult. Tell me about, if you can,
在 Apple 上。太令人兴奋了，我迫不及待想看了。我知道，我现在正努力用这个系统观看，你知道这个叫 PICS 的东西吗，他们会发给你，然后你可以尝试在上面看剧？这真的很难。非常难。你能讲讲吗，如果你能在上面看剧的话。这真的很难。非常难。你能讲讲，如果可以的话，
a really crazy Groundlings theater story, like something that went wrong or awry. Oh, God. Fucking Sean. I love it. I love you so much. I love it. Because I used to do a show with the Groundlings.
一个特别疯狂的“土地班”喜剧团的故事，比如有什么事情搞砸了或者出错了。哦，天哪。肖恩这混蛋。我太爱了。我太爱你了。太棒了。因为我以前在“土地班”演过一个秀。
You did? Yeah, with my friend Darlene Hunt. She is Darlene. Darlene Hunt, and it was called... No, it was called... Sorry, and then something went wrong, Shani? Name of the show, does it really matter that much? As soon as you wrap this up, we'll get to the answer?
真的吗？对，和我朋友达琳·亨特一起。她就是达琳。达琳·亨特，那个秀叫……不对，叫……抱歉，然后出什么差错了吗，肖尼？秀的名字，真的有那么重要吗？等你把这个收尾了，我们再回答这个问题？
Platonically incorrect. Oh man, thank God we paused. And then what happened? Oh, that's good. It's a good title, right? Oh, he's proud of himself. No, I just had to wear false teeth and they popped out a couple times.
绝对不正确。哦天哪，感谢上帝我们暂停了。然后呢？哦，那挺好。这是个好标题，对吧？哦，他为自己感到骄傲呢。不，我只是得戴假牙，它们还掉了好几次。
What? No, it's, fuck. No, but I didn't know if you had anything. Because we all have the same friends from the ground, like we all know a lot of the same people. Tim Bagley. It's the stuff that happened backstage that was bad. That's what I'm saying, friends from the groundlings. We all know a lot of people Tim Bagley. It's the stuff that happened backstage That's I'm saying that's bad part, you know, cuz oh, yeah
什么？不，真是，操。不，但我不知道你有没有什么想法。因为我们所有人在The Groundlings剧团都有共同的朋友，比如说我们都认识很多相同的人。蒂姆·巴格利。那是后台发生的不好的事情。这就是我要说的，The Groundlings剧团的朋友。我们都认识很多人，蒂姆·巴格利。那是后台发生的事情，这就是我要说的不好的部分，你知道，因为，哦，对
No, I have a lot of those cuz I am always working on my filter. Mm-hmm with people Because I to me facts don't hurt, you know So, you know like letting someone know like oh, I don't know about that sketch. It's more of like a ditty than a sketch. I mean, you just sort of, like, it feels like it belongs on a cruise ship. So this is a recurring theme.
不，我有很多这种经历，因为我总是在过滤自己的言行。嗯……和别人沟通时。因为对我来说，事实是不会伤人的，你知道的。所以，你知道，比如让某人知道，哦，我对那个小品不太确定。与其说是个小品，不如说是个小曲。我的意思是，你给人的感觉，就像是它应该出现在游轮上一样。所以这是一个反复出现的主题。
So when you go like, oh, you're just like your character. Like, that's just something in your filter. Well, no, but here. Well, but I know I do that. So sometimes that's my joke too. Do you know what I mean? Then I'm being the person with no filter. How about just, you're know I do that. So sometimes that's my joke too. Do you know what I mean? Then I'm being the person with no filter. How about just you're not full of shit
所以当你去说，哦，你就像你的角色一样。这只是你过滤器里的一部分。好吧，不，但是在这儿。好吧，但我知道我会这么做。所以有时候那也是我的笑话，你知道我的意思吗？那我就是那个毫无过滤的人。不如就说，你知道我会这么做。所以有时候那也是我的笑话，你知道我的意思吗？那我就是那个毫无过滤的人。不如就说，你满口胡言
and I think that's great. Thanks, Jason. Don't change that. I mean, you're not hurting people's feelings, right? You've got a filter that keeps you from really chopping somebody's legs off. I mean, you know, you gotta amp it up just a little bit to get to him. Yeah. But that, I guess, you know, you gotta amp it up just a little bit to get to him.
而且我认为这很棒。谢谢，杰森。别改变这个。我的意思是，你又没有伤害别人的感情，对吧？你有一个过滤器，能防止你真的去砍断别人的腿。我的意思是，你知道，你得稍微加强一点才能影响到他。是的。但那个，我想，你知道，你得稍微加强一点才能影响到他。
Yeah. But that I guess was rough, and I didn't think it was rough to say. To me, it's just a song. But we were all being asked, what do you think of this piece? So, to be fair. But, and that, by the way, was Mike Hitchcock,
是的。但我想那挺刺耳的，而且我不觉得说出来有什么刺耳的。对我来说，这只是一首歌。但我们当时都被问到，你对这个作品怎么看？所以，平心而论。但顺便说一句，那是迈克·希区柯克，
who's hilarious. Hilarious. Genius talent. And then one time backstage at the groundings, he came and he said, I had a dream about you last night. I said, oh, you did? He said, yeah, you threw acid in my face. He's really funny, that guy.
他太搞笑了。太搞笑了。天才。然后有一次在The Groundlings的后台，他走过来对我说，我昨晚梦到你了。我说，哦，是吗？他说，对，你把酸泼在我脸上了。那家伙真的很有趣。
From the thing, is that because of the, he's like, that was my dream. Well, speaking of dreams, we've taken up way too much of your time, Lisa Q. You are a dream. You are a dream. Thank you for coming on, honey. We love you. I really enjoyed talking to you. Please say hi to Michelle.
从这件事来看，是因为那个，他说，那是我的梦。好吧，说到梦，我们占用了你太多时间了，莉莎·库卓。你真是一个梦幻般的嘉宾。你太棒了。谢谢你来做客，亲爱的。我们爱你。我很喜欢和你聊天。请代我向米歇尔问好。
I will. Ask him if to Michelle. I will. Yeah, ask him if he needs new wedges. What's a wedge? It's a golf club. I saw Michelle twice last week. Oh, you did? Yeah. Yeah, that's great. I love golf stories. No, that's another podcast. Listener, that's another podcast. Listen, that's sarcasm. Alright, Liz, we love you. I'm sure we'll see you soon. Yeah, I hope so.
我会的。问他米歇尔的事。我会的。是的，问问他是否需要新的球杆。什么是球杆？那是高尔夫球杆。我上周见了两回米歇尔。哦，是吗？对。是的，那太好了。我很喜欢高尔夫的故事。不，那是另一个播客。听众们，那是另一个播客。听着，那是讽刺。好了，莉兹，我们爱你。我相信我们很快就会再见到你的。对，希望如此。
Yeah, so great to see you. You're the best. You guys are. Thank you for doing this. Do I log off? Do I just slam it? Yeah, just slam it or do whatever you want. Okay. Bye. Okay. Yeah, you can just. Bye.
对，见到你太棒了。你是最棒的。你们都是。谢谢你们做这些。我要挂断了吗？还是直接挂掉？对，直接挂掉或者随便你想怎么样。好吧。拜拜。好的。是的，你可以直接。拜拜。
Bye. Bye. The great. I think the great Lisa Kudrow. You think anybody ever calls her LK? Why not? I would call her LK. That's a good. We call you JB, but nobody says WA
拜拜。拜拜。伟大的。我认为伟大的莉莎·库卓。你觉得有人会叫她LK吗？为什么不呢？我会叫她LK。那挺好的。我们叫你JB，但没人叫WA
because that's too much work. No, it's not fun. Yeah. It's tough. SH, not fun. JB shh, shh. JB, just kind of like that shitty. Like a butler. Some kind of a, yeah, I don't know where I got that from,
因为那太费劲了。不，不好玩。是的。很难。SH，不好玩。JB，嘘，嘘。JB，听起来有点像那个糟糕的。就像个管家。某种，是的，我不知道我是从哪里听到这个的，
but maybe I should, but LK is good to say, right? Okay, okay. You should workshop it, man. Yeah, boy, we're doing that now, right? Yeah, just run it out there. Listeners go ahead and call in while we're still on. But isn't she good? You know, Jay, you said a while ago about Larry David,
不过也许我应该这么叫，但叫LK挺好听的，对吧？好吧，好吧。你应该打磨一下，老兄。对啊，我们现在不就在这么做吗？对，那就直接拿出去说说。听众们，趁我们还没下线，赶紧打进电话来吧。不过她不是很棒吗？你知道，杰伊，你前不久说起拉里·戴维，
you were like, boy, you just did, you did Seinfeld, then you did Curb Your Enthusiasm, you just did really two things that were, I mean, you did other things, of course, but two shows that were just hit huge. And she did many shows that hit, like, and movies and stuff. And because she takes the time to create characters and like specificity of all of and stuff. And she takes the time to create characters and specificity of all of that stuff.
你说，天哪，你刚做完，你先是做了《宋飞传》，然后你做了《抑制热情》，你真的只是做了两件，我的意思是，你当然也做了别的事，但这两个节目真的是超级大热。而她演了许多大热的节目，还有电影之类的。而且因为她花时间去塑造角色，并且对所有这些细节都精益求精。而且她花时间去塑造角色和所有这些细节。
And to me, she's always taken the time and the energy to make something great or make sure it can be great. Yeah, and the whole people I talk to, people I hear from, she's universally thought of as just like high taste, really smart comedy, which comes from being a good actor, I think, you know? I mean, she says that she's not that interested in drama, or at least she said in the beginning,
对我来说，她总是花时间和精力去创作伟大的作品，或者确保作品能够变得伟大。是的，我交流过的人，我听到的人，大家普遍认为她品味高雅，喜剧非常聪明，这源于她是一个好演员，我认为，你知道吗？我的意思是，她说她对戏剧不太感兴趣，或者至少她在刚开始时说过，
she wasn't interested in drama class. I'll bet if she took a dramatic role, which she'd probably done. Yeah, she has done, yeah. But that she makes you cry real quick. Yeah. Yeah, she's awesome. And just such a talent.
她对戏剧课不感兴趣。我敢打赌，如果她去演一个戏剧角色，她可能已经演过了。是的，她演过，是的。但她能让你很快哭出来。是的。是的，她太棒了。而且真的是个天才。
And she's so... It's funny that she plays that character of Phoebe on Friends Who's sort of kind of out there and whatever. And yet Lisa's so razor sharp, like so smart. I know razor sharp. And she got her beginnings, you know, being smart by going to Vassar, studying that one science. And working in a doctor's office.
她太……有趣的是，她在《老友记》里扮演菲比那个角色，有点古怪什么的。然而莉莎却如此敏锐，非常聪明。我知道，思维极其敏锐。她最初的成名，你知道的，是因为她很聪明，去了瓦萨学院，专攻某一门科学。并在医生办公室工作。
Biology. Oh, oh, oh, yes, sorry. Bye. Bye. Smart. Nice. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
生物学。哦，哦，哦，是的，抱歉。再见。再见。聪明。不错。聪明。Less。聪明。Less。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
Less。聪明。Less。聪明。Less。聪明。Less。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smartjarff. SmartLess If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. It's all a lighthearted nightmare on our podcast, Morbid. We're your hosts. I'm Alina Urquhart.
Less。聪明。SmartLess。如果您喜欢SmartLess，现在就可以通过加入Wondry App或苹果播客上的Wondry Plus，提前收听无广告的节目。在您离开之前，请在Wondry.com/survey上填写一份简短的问卷，让我们了解您。在我们的播客《Morbid》中，一切都是一场轻松愉快的噩梦。我们是您的主持人。我是阿丽娜·厄克特。
And I'm Ash Kelly. And our show is part true crime, part spooky, and part comedy. The stories we cover are well-researched. He claimed and confessed to officially killing up to 28 people. With a touch of humor. I just like to go ahead and say that
我是阿什·凯利。我们的节目部分内容是关于真实犯罪的，部分是诡异的，部分是喜剧。我们涵盖的故事都经过了充分的研究。他声称并供认总共杀害了多达28人。并带有一点幽默感。我只想提前说一下，
if there's no band called Malevolent Deity, that is pretty great. With a touch of humor, a dash of sarcasm, and just garnished a bit with a little bit of cursing. And if you're a weirdo like us and love to cozy up to a creepy tale of the paranormal, or you love to hop in the wayback machine and dissect the details of some of history's most notorious crimes, you should tune in to our podcast, Morbid. Follow Morbid on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to episodes early and ad free by joining Wondery Plus and the Wondery app or on Apple podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果没有一支叫“邪恶神明”的乐队，那可就太棒了。带有一点幽默感，一丝讽刺，再点缀上一丁点粗话。如果你和我们一样是个怪咖，喜欢依偎着听一个毛骨悚然的超自然故事，或者你喜欢坐上时光机去剖析历史上一些最臭名昭著的犯罪细节，你应该收听我们的播客《Morbid》。在Wondry App或任何你获取播客的地方关注《Morbid》。通过加入Wondry App或苹果播客上的Wondry Plus，你可以提前收听无广告的节目。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。